à tous salut stouf ben écoute moi ça va
très bien je me réveille tranquillement
je suis au café hein je suis au café
mais je pense que bah pas mal de viewers
bah ça va être le même le même truc hein
tout le monde s'est réveillé tôt stouffe
pour cette dernière journée en fait du
championnat du monde de Blitz et rapide
qu'il y avait eu avant ça va toi tu es
pas trop fatigué ça va chez moi il est
il est quasiment 8h donc bon j'ai une
heure de moins que vous hein donc bah
bon après c'est la c'est le matin c'est
la dernière journée comme tu le dis et
puis on a de belles affiches aujourd'hui
pour le choix du monde on a du coup
Nakamura qui s'est un petit peu envolé
qui a un point d'avance sur euh ça sent
vraiment
45 du coup deux boss guiris
et rapport
et ensuite on a bien sûr
Jules Moussard néo français qui fait un
super super tournoi hier auteur d'une
magnifique victoire contre carvana
et aujourd'hui qui a 8 et demi du coup
sur 12 et qui va jouer avec les Noirs
contre fedoce qui est assez rigolo c'est
qu'après cinq rondes on disait que Jules
était un petit peu en perdition on
disait qu'il pouvait revenir parce que
au début tournoi avant ces cinq
premières rondes on avait une grosse
attente par rapport à Lyon on sait qu'il
est très fort en cadence en cadence
beats aussi en cadence lente donc on
l'attendait on avait été déçu dans un
premier temps et admiratif dans un
second temps quand il est complètement
revenu jusqu'à éclater
carwana comme tu l'as dit et souffle
donc bah super pour Jules mais plus dur
pour mvl
qui c'est un petit peu écroulé en fin de
en fin de
journée hier bon la fatigue il y a trois
jours de rapides avant c'est c'est pas
évident et puis MVP qui a du coup si
c'est demi sur 12 déjà on peut voir un
petit peu les espoirs de titres
s'envoler il a trois points et demi de
retard sur Naka quasiment terminé autant
dire que c'est
qui fasse
quasiment 909 et que n'a qu'un fasse un
mauvais tournoi enfin voilà c'est ça
même quarantaine qui a quand même 9
points qui a quand même aussi deux
points et demi c'est un éventuellement
en étant très très imaginatif hein parce
que ça va être extrêmement compliqué
même podium il faut vrai faire un 8 sur
9 minimum
en fait pas 8 mais enfin voilà il fait
beaucoup de points et c'est compliqué en
tout cas Maxime on va regarder toujours
un on va voir un peu ce qui ce qui nous
fait mais s'il fait pas un casier
perfect ça va être compliqué pour lui
exactement et voilà sinon bah Jules bah
il a 8 et demi donc tu as deux points
d'avance sur Maxime et du coup juste un
point de retard sur Naka et un demi
point de retard sur sur quinzen et enfin
le caractère du bœuf Guiri et rapport le
groupe le groupe poursuivant de Naka
donc 3 accords possibles pour Jules qui
est qui est encore dans la course et
donc ça fonctionne stof évidemment il
faut gagner et que Naka se craque mais
ça c'est pas trop le problème de Jules
Julie va faire son travail comme il l'a
fait hier je pense qu'il avait pas fait
exprès de se retrouver à deux sur cinq
même certains nous parlaient d'un
sous-marin
mais non en fait c'est juste que bah il
essaye de jouer correctement c'est parti
et des fois bah ça se passe mieux et il
avait perdu aussi contre des joueurs qui
sont très intéressants on rappelle que
tous les joueurs sont quasiment grand
maître dès qu'on avance dans les tables
et grand maître de super niveau une fois
qu'on rentre dans les 20 premières
tables et même des fois on a vu
Sébastien Mazet qui est en difficulté
dans son noir il a joué Adly hier lors
de la dernière ronde enfin c'est c'est
l'horreur quoi c'est même quand vous
ratez c'est dur quoi
extrêmement fort ça il faut le rappeler
on a 200 joueurs sur le 200 joueurs on a
à peu près 180 grammes enfin c'est un
truc comme ça et donc même quand tu es
dans la table tu joues encore des des
joueurs qui qui sont redoutables
à plus 2005 quasiment 2006 exactement
après c'est pour ça qu'on est là tu vois
les joueurs qui ont 2006 ils vont pas
pouvoir champion du monde normalement
ils viennent pour pour je pense pour
s'amuser et pour je contrôle les
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc il faut
profiter un peu tout ça même si c'est
difficile
et
je trouve que toi tu avais vraiment
envie de faire ce tournoi moi c'est
pareil on n'a pas les 25 50 mais c'est
vrai que à titre perso je sais que tu as
la même philosophie c'est vraiment on
aime bien les se coltiner des des forts
pour prendre plein la gueule par moment
et des fois les accrocher et faire des
grosses parties et on sait que c'est
possible sur une partie de battre à peu
près n'importe quel joueur bon de
préférence sous les 2700 parce qu'après
ça commence à être vraiment un autre
monde mais mais on s'amuse on joue parce
qu'on est passionné et on a envie
d'aller affronter ces joueurs là et les
meilleurs joueurs les les grands maîtres
ont envie d'aller taper le gratin
mondial aussi voilà
c'est clair en fait tu vois un tournant
comme ça quand moi j'utilisais l'autre
jour on les voit un peu la caméra là on
a on a la zavik juste devant nous là à
chaque fois que tu fais un mètre et ben
tu tu te crois enfin tu crois que je me
star mondiale
ce soit que ce soit un joueur du de
l'Open mixte ou même féminin tu vois
et ben je trouve que c'est juste
fabuleux quoi tu vois c'est un rêve
enfin tous les meilleurs joueurs du
monde sont présents dans la salle et du
coup faire un tournoi avec ces jours-là
mais c'est juste c'est génial quoi même
hier enfin on parlait un petit peu de
Sébastien Mazet qui faisait un temps
difficile en blitz je pense qu'il est
content d'être là il est content de voir
tout ce top niveau et de pouvoir aussi
suivre
Jules et
on voit d'ailleurs Maxime qui est déjà
installé
[Musique]
il est souvent capitaine donc il a
l'occasion il connaît tout seul tout ce
grade là mais là il a l'occasion de de
les jouer c'est pour lui c'est une
expérience même c'est quand Blitz et en
rapide bah c'est bien pour lui ça fait
partie de son entraînement il pourra
débriefer ses parties de retour à la
maison et du coup ça va ça va lui faire
ça va lui faire le plus grand bien pour
se motiver aussi derrière quand tu as
pris cher contre d'efforts tu vas
regarder pourquoi et te motiver pour des
tournois derrière plus plus confidentiel
que ce chauffeur du monde
qui arrive yes salut à tous un poignard
tout ça tous ceux qui qui arrivent sur
le chat
je vous remercie de bien
nous suivre dès le matin dès le matin
parce que c'est
9h chez vous sachez que chez moi il est
à 1h de moins de 8h chez moi
donc il a fait vraiment un effort là ce
matin je pense que il serait bien resté
il serait bien resté au lit même s'il
aime les échecs
un peu tout match ce matin je vais vous
dire que je me suis réveillé avant mon
chat ce qui est ce qui est incroyable
donc là c'est l'utile tous les matins me
réveille et ben je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est moi qui l'ai
réveillé et il était pas content donc il
comprend un petit peu ce qui me fait
tous les matins à commencer ta matinée
par une victoire souffle direct c'est ça
je suis pas Portugal je suis sur les
îles Canaries c'est en Espagne c'est au
large du Maroc si tu veux on voit Jules
la caméra Jules donc on fait de seguieff
j'ai eu la droite bien sûr et salut mala
comment vas-tu malin
[Musique]
et en tout cas oui ça va pas ça va pas
être facile non plus pour Jules
puisqu'on sait que fedof on le voit dans
tous les gros tournois de cadence rapide
déjà en cadence lente c'est 27 mais
au-delà de ça on le voit en ce moment
partout donc et il a des gros résultats
quand même fait d'Oc même contre les
très forts à part peut-être Naka comme
tu le disais c'est son client mais il le
joue très régulièrement et Jules qui a
une grosse expérience n'a quand même pas
la même expérience récente que vedoci
mondiale c'est ça exactement
Jules il est un petit peu nouveau si tu
veux dans ces dans cette tournoi
internationaux
qui ne participe pas avant tu as vu il a
quand même cette année en 2022 bon il a
été champion de France mais il a aussi
gagné quasiment 100 points hello et
voilà il a complètement explosé cette
année à Jules donc donc du coup bon il a
envie de se frotter un petit peu aux
meilleurs joueurs du monde et c'est tout
à fait légitime et normal et mais avant
peut-être que s'intéressait pas juste
parce que il travaillait pas et voilà
quoi mais là il a fait beaucoup de
progrès il travaille beaucoup et bien
sûr et bien sûr que tout le travail paye
quoi c'est un prodige qui se révèle sur
le tard en fait on peut dire ça parce
que pendant longtemps quand il était
jeune il était un peu au dessus de
Maxime Lagarde qui avait Maxime Lagarde
pris l'ascendant finalement par rapport
à Jules légèrement ce qui n'était pas
trop conforme à ce qu'on pressentait
quand ils étaient plus jeunes on voyait
Jules légèrement au dessus parce que
Maxime Lagarde ça reste à jouer
exceptionnel néanmoins jules a récemment
a repris le lead à la faveur de 100
points hello gagné ce des colossales à
ce niveau là et comme tu l'as dit je
pense que c'est c'est pas dû au hasard
évidemment c'est pas dû à son seul
talent c'est dû au travail et je pense
que c'est dû au sérieux aussi à une
rigueur et je pense que tout cela bah ça
va le motiver à aller essayer d'aller
encore plus haut on parle des quatre
dans ce lentes mais même ce tournoi peut
être un révélateur peut être assez
intéressant par rapport à ça donc on a
envie de voir cette journée on va avoir
envie de voir on a envie de voir si si
confirme ou non
hier il a fait une très grosse partie
contre Caravana et donc déjà enfin juste
avant finir la journée tu vois et là du
coup on va voir un petit peu comment il
va confire aujourd'hui en tout cas j'ai
hâte de voir de voir la suite donc voilà
demande si on pense que Jules peut
passer 2700 connu comme ça ben écoute
Jul il a quasiment 2007
85 un truc comme ça donc il lui il a une
dizaine une quinzaine de points dès 2700
hello donc bien évidemment
que
qu'il est pas loin et que moi je pense
qu'il va les il va les dépasser un jour
ou l'autre
et bien sûr pour les juges aussi donc tu
parles de juges arbitre aussi c'est
marrant
et ben c'est c'est pour eux aussi ça
doit être quelque chose
d'extraordinaire même si je pense que
j'habite de la seconde ont quand même
l'habitude de voir ce joueur là c'est
pas le l'arbitre du dimanche normalement
c'est quand même des arbitres qui vont
l'habitude de ces championnats
internationaux
espagnol que j'ai j'avais rencontré en
tournant qui est très sympa qui
s'appelle resus et
je sais que c'est un très très bonne
arbitre reconnu
par exemple tu vois c'est quand même un
des plus gros open au monde et
donc
voilà bah tiens on a qu'à Moura en
rapport
j'ai cru que le rapport avait demandé à
ce que l'officiel joue F4 et il a joué
E4 mais j'ai peut-être mal vu tu vois
parce qu'on était un peu de côté
qui va dévoiler sa prépa
alors le parti commence
que ce F4 mais je me suis dit c'est
possible alors je vais vous mettre la
vue normale et on va regarder la partie
de de Jules jusque les Noirs
malheureusement vous savez que j'ai pas
la caméra de tous les joueurs donc je ne
peux pas
suivre Jules en caméra par contre on va
suivre étape 6 donc il y a quatre
caméras pendant la 4 des caméras donc il
faut qu'il gagne il faut qu'il gagne
pour pour mériter la cam elle se mérite
au cheval du monde la camasse c'est pas
facile de l'avoir alors que rapport et
Nakamura ont déjà fait nul
ça ça me choque
et j'aime pas ça
me dégoûte un peu
après
pourquoi tu joues pas
bon en tout cas je pense que Arsen n'est
pas forcément
contre le fait qu'il fasse une comme ça
parce que c'est 45 là-bas martyrie aussi
la petite astuce de NACA c'est que bon
même s'il y a des Noirs il peut gagner
il préfère quand même les blancs avec
son style et c'est pour ça que faire nul
noir ça le dérange pas trop il sait que
carène pourra pas gagner toutes ces
parties avec avec les Noirs non plus
donc il estime que ça le ça le ouais ça
maintient son avance assez
confortablement
donc c'est pas le beau jeu on est
d'accord et bon on l'a vu au speedcha
c'est un peu pareil mais après c'est les
règles du speechers qui sont comme ça
vous savez que ça se joue sur un temps
défini à l'avance et enaka avait fait
couler son temps pour tomber à la
pendule dans une position foutue pour
s'assurer la win du match bon on peut
pas le un problème mais c'est encore
pire là de faire nul dans
dans un tournoi de Blitz ça pas ça pas
trop de sens
mais ok donc là du coup Jules non on a
un peu des problèmes encore avec James
com on voit que la jure merci beaucoup
mais c'est pas vrai
on a chaque on va dire 30 secondes
5 6 coups qui se rajoutent
en tout cas vous voyez qu'on est dans un
steam plutôt catalan ou le Fou est venu
en G2 pour dominer le fousset 8 mais
comme comme je l'a mis son fou en B7 il
n'y a rien du tout
donc B5 a été joué vu la jouer à 5 pour
essayer de casser un peu la structure et
au bureau des cases parce que le plan B4
contre quand même des cases et là
peut-être plus tard on peut essayer on
peut imaginer en tout cas un cavalier
qui pourrait venir en C5 pour contrôler
des cases contre les centres le pions B5
case là aussi ce qu'il y en a qui va
être intéressant pour échanger les fous
et
c'est le fou B2 qui est quand même assez
assez puissant sur la diagonale
ce que je pourrais te demander un petit
quelque chose parce que tu sais depuis
tout à l'heure je me dis il y a quelque
chose qui est bizarre et en fait je me
dis que je suis en train de regarder
dans le stream depuis tout à l'heure
les positions et je me dis c'est bizarre
d'habitude je regarde pas cet écran là
il y a quelque chose de bizarre tu vois
c'est mon aspect technique tu vois comme
ça et là je me dis aujourd'hui on était
en avance si vous voulez et on a bien
discuter avant le stream avec stouf et
depuis et depuis tout à l'heure j'étais
un petit peu en retard
en fait j'avais pas l'écran de tout pour
une fois mais je suis en train là
tranquille de de faire des commandes
j'avoue qu'on a on a complètement zappé
bah écoute on va le faire en direct
donc n'hésitez pas à rejoindre du coup
le lien que je t'ai envoyé Kevin
merci à toi je suis désolé j'étais
oublié non mais j'aurais pu me signaler
aussi
à faire tu vois il y a un petit aspect
technique qui peut qui peut rentrer en
ligne de compte c'est
jamais jamais évident de penser à tout
tu sais j'ai toujours pas compris quoi
ça fait énorme
bon quand même la position de Jules donc
je disais que c'était sans problème bon
normalement ce genre de position c'est
vraiment égale pourquoi parce que les ça
se ressemblent les positions il y a
juste un tout petit la petite cassé 6
qui pourrait être un point d'accroche
pour l'adversaire donc faut faire juste
attention à cela mais en même temps les
pions avant c'est blanc des fois c'est
bien et ça peut être aussi des
faiblesses à terme avec des lâchés de
cases le pion à 3 qui viendra en 4
serait faible etc etc donc c'est pas si
facile que ça
donc là du coup on a encore enfin hier
on a eu des problèmes un peu de
connexion avec tierce.com
avec
avec le site de la fille hein tu sais
les joueurs qui enfin les étudier l'été
et on a pas mal de retard sur les coups
donc on va voir un petit peu si en
actualisant la page
tout ce qu'on avait dit un peu des
manœuvres
la position blanche en
proposant un maximum d'échanges
donc c'est un peu énervant l'histoire du
pionbé 6 qui se fait taper avec le
kfc46
quand même deux choses qui peuvent
embêter un petit peu les Noirs cette
position
[Musique]
c'est toujours un pion qu'il faut sur
lequel il faut cabane œil c'est pas
évident à tenir pour Jules mais encore
une fois on sait on va pas bien répandu
on sait pas ce qui se passe
c'est vraiment frustrant
je vais voir si on a une caméra mais je
crois que je crois que les deux caméras
sont sur 45 malheureusement
[Musique]
parce que vous savez on a les vu grand
angle
glace c'est en train de se gâter
légèrement pour pour Jules
5 les tours blanches sont beaucoup plus
actifs vous le voyez
c'est à dire qu'il a sacrifié un pion
fedo pour le récupérer c'est un pseudo
sacrifice du coup il va le récupérer
dans de bonnes circonstances avec une
position plus active
et le cavalier B7 reste en l'air
je devrais faire d'apprendre
et après mettre un cavalier d'être en C5
de 3 je sais pas si je peux y arriver
genre
je pense que 4 c'est bien joué
alors j'ai vu que Carlsen avait fini je
pense qu'il a
il a peut-être mystifié son adversaire
ou non
donc
juste qu'il respecte énormément
il a l'air très très respectueux cette
cette personne me fait vraiment une
bonne impression dans
dans l'aspect fair-play
et là on sait pas comment s'est passé
mais
Jules a une pièce en plus dans la
position souffle
et oui
on va essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe
parce qu'en fait la connexion
malheureusement voilà j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive à rien à voir
j'arrive pas à voir je suis désolé on
fait ce qu'on peut ici à technique
3 2 tours à huit et la tour qui arrive
se laisser emprise il y a ma du couloir
si je prends la tour et le cavailleux 5
d'un bout je te reprends un gros
oubliant on a l'impression de la part de
feu de CF qui a la chaîne pièce
il a complètement craqué au début
c'était malin sauf il voulait faire
matte du couloir en cas de de perte de
pièces il avait une compensation plus
énorme sauf que là il y a plus il y
avait plus que dalle malheureusement
[Musique]
c'est pas facile de s'en sortir
j'espère qu'il va continuer on voit pas
les pendules c'est frustrant
encore une fois c'est pas combien de
temps ils ont c'est ça
c'est difficile dans le speed
mais normalement je pense que ça comme
c'est visible
et malheureusement c'est compliqué les
la connexion qui arrive pas vraiment à
notre serveur
on n'arrive pas à bien à suivre les
coups
je vois qu'un téléphone
on sait pas encore du coup
on est bloqué on a on a les positions
mais pare-brise
les femmes jouent entre très importants
ça fait nulle c'est un petit peu dommage
parce que dans la position initiale
n'était pas obligé de perdre une pièce
un peu regretter il a réussi à trouver
du contre Jeff et dossehif avec cavalier
5 et Jules n'a pas réussi à se dépêtrer
de cette situation alors qu'un simple
tour à 7 ici garantissait un avantage
durable qui empêche cavaler des sets et
là du coup termine la partie parce que
je vais
prendre quelque chose comme ça
ça vous avez
et après
non j'aurais F6
je voulais faire un chantage cavalier E5
cavalier 5 à sS6 mais tu peux peut-être
me bouffer
ça marchera pas trop ce genre de choses
je pense
mais
oui en plus tu peux sacrifier peut-être
ta tour après sur le cavalier bon bref
il y a plusieurs
mais ok bon
Jules qui était pas très bien en début
de partie donc ils sont encore quand
même pas mal mais un petit peu dommage
quand même pour pour
la partie de ma Mégara je crois que
c'est ma meilleure offre qui a craqué
complètement ça final
contre le MI le MI Mama 19 là il a donné
toute sa position il va être ma
meilleure
encore une fois on voit pas vous avez vu
la position sur l'échiquier mais
on va voir le petit H3
maintenant je vais être tranquille
il y a trop de menaces
en train de souffrir énormément
[Musique]
malheureusement on n'a pas la position
sur Sanchez comme
des échecs en place
il n'arrive pas à s'en sortir le joueur
n'arrive pas à passer incroyable ça va
faire une je pense non
vous voyez la position sur sur la caméra
et moi j'ai réussi à faire craquer
la grande caméra pour pour ce match tout
je vais vous la mettre en grande caméra
parce que c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'on voit on voit rien
c'est comme bug pas mal et quand est-ce
qu'on bug malheureusement
6 secondes contre 6 secondes donc
il est tombé
il est tombé il a oublié mais il aurait
perdu un la stuff parce que le pion
était maintenant en l'air puis on met
avec Dame trois pions il y a gagné
incroyable ce jeune qui a battu hier
qui était parti un petit peu en colère
hier dans la partie
23 33 je peux vous dire que c'est pas un
peno pour les joueurs du top niveau loin
de là
mais ok 23 33 ça doit être son son hello
en
partie Bleach je pense
disons
[Musique]
c'est un joueur
c'est un joueur qui qui normalement ne
peut pas figurer à ce niveau-là de
compétition parce qu'un écart énorme
c'est du coup une performance
monstrueuse alors ici ici là je vois son
tournoi d'ailleurs à mamadina qui vient
de battre qui vient de battre ma manière
off il a un tournoi assez incroyable il
a battu Kova neuf il a battu Titi pop
qui a 2006 il a battu asadly il a battu
Adli il a battu muradli il a battu plein
de lit et tu peux trop chiant il a battu
blue bom et là il veut une balle
à plus de 27,50 avant la ronde donc là
il va s'approcher d'une perf à 2800
en tout cas
c'est un super joueur
donc personne qui a gagné donc on a bien
raison avec ça et pas mal de nuls
notamment bon rapport on a vu on a vu
tout bof à Nice guéri aussi que celle
qui a fait nul du coup 45 qui va se
rapprocher d'un demi point de de NACA
en vrai il y a pas tant que ça nul
franchement ça joue dans l'ensemble il y
a des rondes où il y a un peu plus de
nuls mais globalement il pousse au bout
on a vu un contre-exemple avec Nakamura
mais sinon on a vu très très peu de nuls
qu'on pourrait qualifier de salon c'est
à dire des nuls hyper rapides à vert
avec un une sorte de consentement
implicite des joueurs
ça se fait pas ça se fait pas trop alors
que Maxime n'a fait que nul et pour
revenir l'essence s'amenuisent la marque
mvl a fait nul contre Petrossian donc
voilà ça ça commence mal hein
pour faire quelque chose il faut qu'il
fasse 100% dans cet endroit
on n'y est pas mais ça doit être dur il
doit savoir que c'est quasiment foutu
donc il faut qu'il y ait un petit coup
de pouce du destin dans ces cas-là que
les adversaires jouent moins bien qui
commencent à bien jouer pour que il
retrouve une sorte d'énergie positive
qui lui permet d'aller plus loin ouais
qui a fait nul
contre un jour à 21
[Musique]
nul ok je vais vous mettre les résultats
à jour sur sur Obs j'espère que les
caméras vont vont se remettre à jour
quand même enfin pendant pas la caméra
mais que les que cheeseccom va revenir
un petit peu
est dangereux on avait signalé avec
stouf il était dans nos pronos je vous
rappelle que nos pronos pour tout
c'était Carlson nepo Naka mvl regga easy
et pour ma part Carlson Naka n'est pas
Douda mvl et on voit qu'on avait essayé
d'être corpo d'être un petit peu chauvin
et ben au final stouf on peut déjà se
dire que
nos mvl 4 et 5 on voit pas trop comment
ça peut arriver on va très bien Maximus
j'espère que vous aussi ça va de bon
matin
en tout cas on est mal avec nos pronos
pour l'instant je rappelle que c'est
stouf qui mène la danse puisque hier
à la faveur d'une finale turfu contre
tour entre mvl et yazancaf sauf ma
proposé un petit Paris et moi j'étais
plutôt favorable au fait que rien ne
Sèvres allait réussir à faire tenir sa
nul théorique ce que je me disais le
joueur russe il va réussir à gérer sa
finale même sous pression du temps
et ça n'a pas été le cas stuff a bien
rigoler au bout de 30 secondes j'avais
perdu deux subs et du coup il était pas
malheureux avec ce petit Paris bien joué
ce souffle encore mais vu que du feu
pensez à faire une bonne affaire et 30
secondes plus tard j'ai le sentiment de
mettre fait rouler roulant la farine
exactement sous donc voilà ça c'était le
petit
ça vous intéresse ça nous intéresse tout
ça je vais vous le montrer en fait
directement à l'écran attends je vais
juste
décoller ça la technique attendez ça
arrive
la technique punaise et qu'est-ce qu'il
est solide quoi alors voilà le tournoi
est ici
donc on a du coup
Carlson rapport donc vous voyez que
Carlson à 10 points et Nakamura à 17,5
donc du coup personne qui est revenu un
demi point du coup de de Nakamura donc
personne qui va compter rapport avec les
Blancs donc vous inquiétez pas rapport
ici enfin Carson ne prendra pas la nuit
sans jouer contre rapport c'est une
partie qui va jouer blanc en noir car ça
ne pense qu'il va toujours le tournoi
[Musique]
dans ce genre de tournoi il est
impressionnant parfois il fait quelques
gaffes d'ailleurs en mettant trop la
pression au temps en exagérant un petit
peu ce trait là mais tous les joueurs
qui mettent la pression au temps ont
certaines déconvenues on a bien vu
d'ailleurs dans le championnat du monde
de rapides cars scène qui l'a gagné ben
faire une énorme gave contre artemiev
avec 10 minutes contre une minute donc
ça arrive à tout le monde les gars mais
mettre la pression au temps c'est une
stratégie gagnante sur le long terme si
on le fait bien c'est ça clairement donc
donc voilà là on a pas mal de parties
qui sont très très importantes ont aussi
artemief du bof guérir un Dream et on
voit aussi des table de 5 apparaître
Jules avec 9 points contre Douda donc
encore une fois une partie hyper
importante pour Jules Jules qui doit
essayer de l'emporter avec élan pour
essayer de rester dans le dans la course
au titre donc partie encore hyper
intéressant et je pense qu'on va essayer
de voir enfin de regarder en tout cas
cette partie Jules qui sera
malheureusement pas en caméra vous savez
qu'on a que on a que quatre tables et
que du coup une table 5 donc encore un
petit effort Jules et il pourra il
pourrait être sur la caméra pas facile
de les avoir les camarades à mon avis il
fallait gagner il a fait que nul on va
sortir direct par les caméras dans ton
rapide on a eu une fois mvl c'était la
dernière ronde parce qu'un autre gamer
qui euh qui était du coupable
2 et dans le but mais pas encore eu de
français pour l'instant en caméra mais
on espère voir Jules très prochainement
alors que mvl n'est pas n'est pas sur
les apparements sont affichés on va voir
quand même ce que on on va un petit peu
mvl contre contre qui joue
à 23 33 on a parlé
pas facile et on voit darda faire une
très belle remontée il se retrouve à 8.5
il sait très très bien que son poulain
peut faire quelque chose
donc il est chaud je pense pas de métal
alors que MVF joue contre Andrew Tang en
broutant que c'est le petit génie
d'internet on en a parlé plusieurs fois
hier c'est un des meilleurs joueurs de
Bullet au monde et
donc c'est un très mauvaise bon bien sûr
Maxime et 1000 fois plus fort mais pour
faire un petit peu attention si il est
pas en forme et que quand autant me
l'est ça peut ça peut ça peut se
compliquer
où est Sébastien Bazet ou Sébastien
Bazet avec 5 points il vient de faire
nul en 2100 et là il affronte safchenko
encore une fois vous voyez pas un
appareil moins facile qui joue encore un
grand maître fort grand maître à 200600
noir donc on va voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe avec Sébastien
il est un peu en roue libre Sacha
va réussir à lui faire encore plus mal
c'est ce qu'on lui souhaite à celle pour
remonter dans le milieu de tableau et
avoir des des gros matchs sinon il
jouera pour racler un peu le le fond le
fond du championnat
dur dur
pour ça on a dit tournoi très très
difficile on va difficile on a une belle
ronde à La Sauve qui s'annonce quand
même
les outsiders qui est un petit peu
reviennent dans le tournoi et tu as
quand je vois quand c'est le rapport et
une dépôt Dakar franchement ça ça
c'est intéressant quoi tu vois tu as
vraiment envie de complètement parce que
tu vois en plus ma carte qui va me
servir nul sans jouer en vrai j'ai envie
de dire
karma ça serait que
qui se lève ça va se coller par dépôt et
que caracène battre à part tu vois et
qui reviennent voilà c'est ce qu'on
attend c'est le quartier Nathan et car
cette nuit s'en fout il dit ok il fait
des nul et puis moi je vais jouer quoi
tu vois hier quand il avait annoncé dans
une interview que qu'il était pas en
forme et qu'il espérait finir la
première journée de Blitz avec le
maximum de points possible sachant qu'il
était fatigué parce que sentait pas bien
et qui voulait se reposer pour
aujourd'hui du coup le dernier jour de
Blitz pouvoir revenir et marquer le plus
de points et donc là il est venu il a
gagné on a l'impression qu'ils sont un
peu mieux qui s'est reposait en tout cas
de d'hier et on n'a pas perdu dans ce
tournoi il a fait 5000 par contre pour
finir hier c'est ce qui montre qu'il a
été fatigué comme nous disent tous
donc voilà en tout cas
bon moment pas vraiment de favoris entre
45 etc bon à part nos français bien sûr
mais
c'est vrai que
on aime bien un petit peu ce petit ces
petits fight dans les premières tables
là ça peut être suspense dans ce tournoi
et entre Nakamura et 45 c'est vrai que
que c'est deux ans internet qui se
jouent tout le temps on a vu un mode
speechestre tout ça donc c'est quand
même deux favori à chaque fois tout à
fait après tout j'ai l'impression enfin
à titre personnel j'ai une préférence
pour Carson j'ai l'impression que toi
aussi tu t'en vas en scène complètement
complètement par son Carlson je trouve
que c'est un meilleur protège avec et il
est plus classe aussi il y a un double
aspect c'est que bon il est meilleur aux
échecs c'est certain après dans les
cadences ultra rapide c'est une autre
histoire parce que
nakaju extrêmement vite et mets une
pression de dingue donc c'est un très
beau joueur d'échec aussi néanmoins bon
on vient de le voir Carlsen c'est pas du
style à faire nul rapide comme viens
c'est toujours un petit peu ce côté
un peu plus limite on va dire dans la
chambre et tout ça ce qu'on aime aussi
c'est le spectacle mais c'est toujours
un peu plus limite que Carlsen qui qui
représente je sais pas si je peux faire
une analogie avec avec le tennis c'est
Federer quoi c'est la grande grande
place
[Musique]
peu importe la cadence peu importe le
truc c'est il joue un échec différent
des autres et et c'est extrêmement
extrêmement beau de voir ça quoi alors
que tu as même un Nakamura qui est très
dangereux et qui est très très fort
qu'un des meilleurs roulement c'est plus
l'embrouille tu vois oui mais en fait
c'est quand même l'embrouille d'élite
quoi parce que ce qu'il arrive à faire
il joue comme il a un style un peu plus
bistrot que Carlsen mais c'est le
bistrot mais alors là tu joues ce genre
là c'est tes verts quoi parce qu'il
arrive toujours à te trouver un truc qui
n'existe pas quoi mais tu sais qui veut
des ressources tu sais qu'il va
t'embrouiller ça tu le sais mais c'est
vrai que 45 lui c'est plus positionnel
c'est c'est plus c'est des vrais échecs
voilà c'est pur comme tu dis il est
capable de faire des parties d'élite en
blitz quoi tu vois et je trouve ça
magnifique
c'est une opposition de style assez
radical d'ailleurs c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui amène à ce qui nous amène à
apprécier d'ailleurs les oppositions
même si hier l'opposition entre les deux
joueurs
a été un petit peu
terne dans le sens où l'ouverture à
amener une position vraiment très plate
car ça n'a bien surpris Nakamura qui a
été obligé de d'aseptiser la position
avec les pièces blanches pour éviter de
perdre rapidement il a fait nul à la
place rapidement et il s'est dit sur le
long terme je vais réussir à la voir en
étant régulier en étant rapide parce que
vous savez Naka il est extrêmement
rapide même si Carlsen n'est pas n'est
pas mauvais sur ce sujet là les échecs
pur c'est pas facile à faire en blitz
même si Carlson y arrive c'est plus
facile de jouer sur les tactiques sur du
calcul là où Excel Nakamura
alors que les joueurs commencent à
s'installer là on voit deux jeunes là en
face de l'autre donc toi le petit qu'on
a vu l'autre fois la caméra
championnat des moins de 14 ans
il y a 12 ans à gauche
ouais 12 ans 2400 hello à gauche et à
droite je sais pas qui c'est non mais
Alex on peut pas dire effectivement on
n'a jamais dit que
que Naka était une buse positionnément
on peut pas se permettre d'accord c'est
un top 10 mondial mais en par rapport à
carlstène et non pas du tout le même
style Naka est beaucoup plus roublard
beaucoup plus pratique dans son approche
du jeu d'échec que les Carsen qui
cherche un peu la vérité tout le temps
du jeu d'échec et qui arrive même en
cadence ultra rapide à jouer pour une
certaine vérité c'est à dire qu'en dit
vérité c'est trouver le meilleur quoi
chaque fois quoi clairement non on a pas
du tout dit que il était mauvais échec
mais si ça c'est le style de jeu si tu
veux c'est le style de jeu ou Naka il va
souvent
jouer des coups qui sont très borderline
et il le sait très bien par exemple il
va accepter de prendre des pions alors
que il va se faire attaquer
il va défendre hyper bien tu vois alors
que par exemple par exemple un joueur
comme comme Carlson il va pas forcément
prendre ses risques là il va plus
essayer de jouer pratique tu vois et en
fait c'est des styles qui sont
complètement différents tu as un style
qui est vraiment mou comme tu l'as dit
je pense pure chez Carlson très propre
on va dire très propre où il va
rallonger pour la case je prends la
colonne tu vois je prends des aspects un
peu positionnés alors que
Naka c'est plus
bah il y aurait des défis à chaque
partie tu vois tu as l'impression et et
il est plus dans le
l'aspect ouais je pense que en gros
c'est c'est le bon mot quoi et mes
leçons c'est après c'est en gros mais au
niveau au niveau
enfin au top niveau quoi d'ailleurs là
contre le match contre contre nepo sa
première parce que ces deux joueurs qui
ont le même style et et donc c'est une
partie qui va être très très
intéressante
qui nous dit qu'il se régale de ta
chaîne Youtube stouf et à la prochaine
pause il pourra nous poser une question
qui le taraude depuis qu'il a commencé
les échecs comme merci pour pour les
petits mots sympas
merci à toi bah écoute n'hésite pas à
nous poser des questions que ce soit sur
sur nos chaînes sur nos trucs ou bien
sûr sur l'échiquier aussi ce qu'on va
voir aujourd'hui en tout cas il y a
c'est un doute ou si vous avez des
parties vous voulez qu'on qu'on voit
n'hésitez pas à nous à nous demander on
essaiera de vous satisfaire au mieux et
un petit saut pour tout voilà histoire
de le suivre sur sa chaîne twitch
voilà vous savez qu'on stream qu'on a
des chaînes YouTube on a qu'on a plein
de choses maintenant du coup n'hésitez
pas à venir nous voir à consulter nos
sites Web respectifs donc
mon stream c'est tout comme vous voyez
sur le chat et mon Youtube c'est tout
fait shake donc voilà si vous voulez
passer nous voir en tout cas ça va être
grand plaisir je vous mets aussi le lien
twitch de
de Kevin Pro Évolution échec qui
d'ailleurs il y a pas longtemps qui a
ouvert une sorte de ta une un site
internet parce que tu peux nous en dire
plus ce Kevin oui voilà maintenant il y
a les cours en ligne aussi si tu veux ce
que je faisais pas avant bon ok j'avais
comme toi chaîne twin chaîne Youtube et
maintenant j'ai une plateforme de cours
en ligne et du coup je vais vous mettre
il y a un petit cadeau pour ceux qui
s'inscrivent à un cadeau qui est gratuit
deux heures et demie pour deux vidéos
avec comme sujet les
[Musique]
c'est vrai que on est entraîneur
professionnel tous les deux depuis déjà
pas mal d'années et donc on donne des
cours en ligne principalement
et donc voilà d'ailleurs s'il y a des
gens qui sont intéressés sur le chat
pour des cours et ben n'hésitez pas à
nous contacter enfin toi je sais pas si
tu prendras des élèves
j'en prends plus parce que je suis full
mais n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à
contacter tout pour prendre des cours
et pour le côté humidité bah c'est le
jeu d'échec je pense qu'il nous a appris
cela après c'est plus facile d'être
humble parce qu'on n'est pas non plus
dans les meilleurs joueurs du monde donc
on se rend bien compte que il y a des
joueurs bien meilleur que nous mais en
tout cas dès que vous vous sentez trop
beau aux échecs le jeu vous ramène à la
réalité
il y a que Magnus qui est vraiment au
dessus du lot alors je vous ai mis du
coup la partie excuse-moi de Jules Jules
année blanc et il faut Douda et il a il
fait face à un hippopotame
méthode Ruiz mais c'est normal c'est
dégueu je dis aux élèves surtout ne
jouez pas ça c'est de la BIP parce que
je déteste ce genre de d'ouverture et il
est en train de faire un hippopotame
j'en reviens pas
alors pourquoi il popotame d'ailleurs
on l'appelle comme ça
vous voyez on joue sur trois rangs et on
attend et l'hippopotame doit être assez
paresseux donc il y a le même état
d'esprit on attend dans la mare là les
trois sur trois rangées et on attend
juste de se faire de se prendre la
grosse attaque
mondiale peut se permettre en blitz déjà
en l'an vous donne pas fait cela et
c'est extrêmement rare si vous voulez on
peut toujours à l'époque avec carpov qui
avait perdu contre E4 à 6 contre miles
alors il y a toujours des anecdotes même
à haut niveau ou un joueur a joué une
bizarre riz et à gagner
là Douda il préfère éviter les lignes
théoriques il estime avoir un petit age
contre Jul Moussard il choisit il
choisit un début un petit peu rare
mais ne reproduisez pas ça à la maison
sinon vous allez vous retrouver étouffé
sur votre orgés votre hippopotame il va
décéder dans la mare donc ne faites pas
ça voilà c'est compliqué il faut ça
vraiment ce qu'on fait on a eu un match
d'ailleurs
c'était en rapide ou Carlson a battu
cette équipe déjà c'était Thomas shevski
je crois en tournant rapide ou Carson a
battu avec les
dents en fait il y a un sacrifice de de
pions de de Jules E5
l'idée le roi noire il veut ouvrir la
position et surprise cavalier prend
voilà il veut tout ouvrir avec la
colonne E le clouage et toutes les
pièces qui peuvent arriver
en tout cas c'est intéressant le choix
de de Jules de jouer de jeu dessin et
d'essayer de j'aime beaucoup
complètement ouvrir la position on est
obligé de prendre et de jouer G5 il va
le jouer un doodle parce qu'il n'y a pas
le choix c'est ça ou c'est la mort voilà
et maintenant faut j'ai trois va être
joué
c'est pas sûr que
l'idée de Jul était très bonne sauf mais
après petit rock maintenant ça va
s'aplatir complètement au niveau du
centre je pense pas sûr qu'il est assez
de compense pour le pion donné il peut
le récupérer à tout moment je crois non
c'est ça mais je crois que la police
un H4 très très intéressant de Jules qui
a
qui a mis le feu dans la position
et là ça peut peut-être plus facilement
qu'elle va prendre
qui peut venir ici il y a c'est ça en
prise c'est un peu dur à trouver je
pense
je sais pas ça pas été joué il a vu
cavalier H2 pour attaquer G4 et
provoquer H5 pour gagner des cases donc
on peut imaginer après H5 un cavalier F1
cavalier E3 pour venir sur ces cases là
c'est la partie d'ailleurs calmer la
position si tu veux tout faire avec un
comment dirais-je cavalier prend E5 une
liquidation générale cette fois avec le
pion G4 je trouvais que mais il veut
gagner mais là les Noirs vont peut-être
sortir de l'étau l'idée là je peux jouer
pour F5 mais il y a le foot C4 en face
de mon roi G8 un vis-à-vis donc je bouge
mon roi joue F5 et là je peux vous dire
que ça va être dur
salut torrent salut ma cousine oui ils
ont fait du mal à la première ils ont
fini la première
donc d'ailleurs c'est passé Mazet aussi
[Musique]
excusez-moi mais ça fait trois fois
parce que déjà hier il a fait nul rapide
et aujourd'hui ça fait déjà deux sur
deux franchement
il mérite rattraper c'est horrible c'est
vraiment c'est pénible à suivre il
mérite de se rattraper je vois bien que
Carlsen la colle un peu un rapport pour
revenir à hauteur de de ma gamora
une position correcte moi j'aime bien la
position de Jules en fait parce qu'il y
a un point
voulu calmer un petit peu les ardeurs de
Jules mais
il a pas profité de son pion F et
maintenant il est un peu coincé même
s'il a un peu plus c'est la des belles
pièces en compense donc la partie est
assez équilibrée
c'est chaud c'est chaud j'aime bien en
pratique les Noirs bon il y avait qui va
venir en décape donc 6 6 qui clou et qui
aussi attaque le pion C7 en cas de
Cavalier rouge
cavaliers en dessin
intérieur maintenant alors que tout à
l'heure j'avais vraiment une grosse
préférence pour les Noirs mais les
joueurs sont obligés de se décider nous
on commande c'est facile on n'a pas de
prise de décision on propose des coûts
mais s'il y a une différence entre le
choisir le coup on voit les coordidas
normaux axtouf mais le choix du coup est
très dur aux échecs on a le droit de
jouer que un coup
et là donc vous voyez Magnus à l'écran
et la partie qu'on suit c'est la partie
de Jules Moussard le champion de France
en titre qui joue le meilleur joueur
polonais Yann Christophe Douda qui est
très régulièrement dans dans le top 10
mondial
un super star
pour l'instant donc
Jules qui a récupéré son pion et qui a
un pion passé en C avec le pion a qui
est faible j'aime beaucoup la position
de vue là
tout compris puisque julie est en train
d'attaquer le pion à 600
il faut voir parce qu'un cavalier qui
peut venir embêter un petit peu la tour
et les pions etc parce que c'est si
grave bon j'ai envie de faire ces quatre
c'est cinq comme souffle des 5 les idées
aussi où tu peux voilà cavaliers
peut-être avoir alors attention
maintenant ça va jouer au time aussi
parce que la position est très
compliquée il y a une Christophe Doodle
doit jouer dame G6 F5 F4 un moment il
doit faire quelque chose à l'elroit
tout à l'heure ils devaient le faire
tour des deux je sais pas trop ce qu'il
veut faire mais il le fait il veut
embrouiller il veut faire peur à Jules
aussi il y a 20 secondes chacun
il faut faire peur aussi à l'adversaire
ce que je pratique la NACA il faut
intoxiquer un peu peut-être deux aussi
au restaurant
on a plus de risques et on a des pions
qui font mal
rapidement il y a eu un bug de Jules au
centre
difficulté là pour il y a D6 avec tu
reprends un chien qui souffre pour le 5
ouh là là ça va je crois que j'ai
complètement gagnant les gars je vois le
roi le roi de Jules qui va être qui va
être bien défendu en H2 alors que le
Renoir complètement ouvert D6 avec tu
reprends H5 les deux tours qui sont
connectés sur la colonne
ouais ok
il y a tout en prise en fait
et sur un tour B1 je peux toujours se
fouet F4 et ranger 3 donc moi il est
vraiment en sécurité j'ai rien à
craindre avec les Blancs alors que je
prends
pas qu'il soit tombé c'est la pendule
qui fait des siennes
il a mangé ici il a deux pions de plus
avec les Blancs maintenant
il a mangé la tour
il y a une blague regardez
Jul qui badouda incroyable jeu qui va
être télévisé enfin télévisé ça y est
enfin en français sur la cam oh là là il
a pris tous les trucs
qui est hyper en forme on a vu hier
qu'il a battu Kawana et là il commence
il bat d'entrer
jean-christo Douda avec les blancs dans
les complications surtout on voit que
les mecs très forts se prennent toujours
des des petites carottes contre Jules
qui est très malin sur le sujet
[Musique]
mais ça y est
complètement perdu
complètement perdu pour
même une enfilade ça par exemple ça pas
vrai j'aurais échec je prends tout et
j'ai un pion qui avance donc il y a à
peu près 0
mais bon
Tour Eiffel
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'ai 8 avec
maths
incroyable retournement de situation
incroyable
ça c'est ouf quoi on aura tout vu dans
ce dans ce dans ce match
attendez les gars on va vous montrer
après la pause là c'est un peu vite mais
on va vous montrer ce qui s'est passé ça
peut vriller ça peut vriller mais je
crois que Magnus est en train de cacher
son roi
qui a gagné regardez la tête de
Carcassonne il est complètement
incroyable incroyable
incroyable car c'est même plus quoi dire
ce vol ça pour le coup vous voyez c'est
pas facile quand même quand vous allez
battre le numéro 1 mondial même si vous
êtes très expérimenté comme Richard
rapporte il s'est mis la pression
franchement on peut dire qu'on aurait
sûrement gagné avec ce souffle la
position sans trop de problèmes et dans
dans les mêmes circonstances sauf que là
le cœur de Richard rapport devait pas le
piquer et il a complètement déconné
parce que ce qu'on a vu
parce que ce qui s'est passé c'était
quand même assez extraordinaire donc là
il y a eu là du coup il y a une tour
avance pour les Noirs mais attention il
va le faire dame donc il y a quand même
des menaces de maths c'est pas si simple
mais pour pour gagner c'est quand même
assez facile en fait vous voyez on
approche le roi là Kevin nous avait dit
qu'il y avait dame D8 qui gagnait en un
coup la partie parce que du coup
d'ailleurs ça gagne pas la partie
c'est ça et là je suis mat vous voyez
mais
tu as plein dedans moi d'un coup tu vois
voilà et ici donc il a fait ça ok il
peut pas parce qu'il y aura des
problèmes
et donc 47 bah il fait ça il me lasse
mat en B7 et ici bah évidemment H4 qui
est bien joué tous ces sites
en un coup en fait après après ça ça et
ben enfilade et je gagne madame c'est
terminé
qui était assez énorme et du coup 4 bon
ok là il fait ranger 5 d'un E3 rouage 5
et ici il a joué
c'est plus si facile surtout en plus là
ici
regardez
ça échange les dames ça clou et du coup
ben quand tu viens là je fais ça et
après ben tu vas venir avec ton roi moi
je sacrifierai ma tour sur l'option et
pendant ce temps-là je fais dame quoi
donc ça a l'air facile mais très très
facilement et après tu mets 8 en fait on
a l'impression que tu plantes une
tactique donc il était en confiance en
jouant ce coup-là Richard rappeur
je fais ça sauf que contre toute attente
s'il y a G8 dames qui gagne la partie
avec les Blancs parce que dame prend
dames
c'est le coup mais il y a Matt en B7 du
coup et si tu prends du coup en F7
demain je prends une dame d'avance c'est
complètement gagnant en fait du coup
après promotion dame c'est un truc de
fou donc il y a eu échec4 et au final
mais écoutez regardez les blancs enfin
vous avez une dame contre une tour
c'est ouf hein j'ai vu de dames le coup
du jour ah ouais bah c'est Dame 8 qui
est vraiment le le gros mauvais coup
merdouillé parce que maintenant il y
avait pas mal de choses à surveiller
entre la promotion et maintenant
on voit que l'ordinateur donne nulle
meilleur pouce c'est ça qui donne
égalité deuxième meilleur coup c'est ça
qui donne égalité ça fait nul
apparemment et dames 8 c'est passé le
troisième coup mais ça perd avec avec
gélules dames c'est ouf quand même
qui du coup rattrape Nakamura grâce à
cette victoire personne qui aurait pu
perdre cette partie et passer et passer
un petit peu bon un point ça aurait été
difficile ça aurait été très dur après
alors que là maintenant tout est relancé
incroyable
la partie un petit peu la partie
parce que il a il a dû bien jouer
évidemment il y a
Richard rapporte
donc échec fou des trois
C4 foot donc le fou qui a bougé trois
fois d'affilée un chacun mais c'est à
peu près normal dans sa position en fait
ici pour vous expliquer un petit peu
l'idée de fouet 5 beaucoup de fois après
B6 et ben les Noirs veulent jouer fois 6
pardon pour échanger les fous de quinge
blanche vous voyez depuis 15 secondes
des Noirs qui est bah le mot est fou des
Noirs si vous voulez qui enfermé dans la
structure alors chez les Blancs et ben
le fou F1 ce serait le bon fou en fait
avec échec on
force un petit peu fou des sets et après
on dit non refuse l'échange des pièces
et le fou en dessert ne veut pas du coup
venir en B5 on a un peu un peu bloqué
ici
donc du coup on a réussi à empêcher faut
assez donc C4 en faire la position pour
que ce soit un petit peu mauvais salut
crazy salut à tous Greg et Galline d'or
chef
et en fait les noirs qui vont jouer une
partie à ses propres
5 c'est un petit peu le coup obligatoire
j'ai envie de dire parce que du coup
sinon tu as peur tout tes pions quoi
c'est assez génial d'ailleurs comme il
est il ouvre une pièce lourd il prend F7
il a D5 qui peut tomber aussi
un rapport
mais il a vu échec il a essayé de de
propriété mais bon car scène et quand
même complètement foutu dans cette
position
c'est quand même
[Musique]
même si vous n'êtes pas correct elle
était très intéressante enfin oui
on est on a quand même chaud
là il y a dame pas facile cette position
[Musique]
apparemment elle a perdu nous dit pas de
métal et pas de métal qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait Daniel mais il a perdu
au-dessus il nous parlait aussi de cette
Mazet il a surveillé pas de métal
qui a aussi perdu apparemment
tour reprend et ça c'est imparable c'est
incroyable
c'est là qu'on voit que les chèques
quand même au final
ils se sont foutus sur la tronche
objectivement par contre
Richard rapporte quand même mérité le
gang et la dominé la partie et
il a gaffé à la fin il avait quand même
pris l'ascendant énorme sur ma nu qui
s'en sort sur un demi miracle d'ailleurs
la tête de Magnus ouais elle est elle
est revenue franchement et on a Jul
quand même vu qui a battu tout d'un ça
c'est la grosse grosse bonne nouvelle du
jour on va pouvoir être un peu chauvin
et pouvoir suivre un français jusqu'à la
fin Jul il y a pas de raison il est en
feu maintenant
de route
je pense qu'ils sont muets en supporters
pour
ouais je pense qu'ils sont là pour
bulles donc je gagne vous mettre les
résultats
sur le twitch donc cette sur 14 pour mvl
vient d'abandonner son titre de champion
du monde de Blitz avec quasiment
mathématiquement ça doit être ça va être
le cas
et n'oublions pas que Jules avait
démarré avec deux sur cinq
très très grosse remonte tada donc je
vais voir si on a les appareils non si
on a des trucs alors je vais vous mettre
la vue de la salle pour que vous voyez
un petit peu c'est plus sympa je trouve
pendant qu'on fait tout ça pendant ce
temps là je vais actualiser un petit peu
la page
et on voit qu'il y a tous les résultats
[Musique]
et la rendre 15 qui est pas encore sorti
qui va arriver très très vite donc un
scène qui a 11 points Naka qui a 11
points
et dubov qui a 17,5
je vois que Jul il a perdu
je suis pas fou hein je vois ça aussi
a perdu pourquoi c'est une erreur
on peut imaginer
je l'avais bien les blancs donc il y a
pas eu ce sera donc normalement il y a
pas de
il avait le temps le score est bien
indiqué je pense que c'est en rentrant
peut-être et que ça va être corrigé
allez on va être positif ça se trouve on
va pas à moins qu'ils aient changé de
table et qui sont trompés que c'était
Guy c'était Jules qui avait
non je sais pas
je ne joue pas la française
non non c'était plutôt bon ouais on a on
a un 01 chez Jules les gars
on se demande un peu ce qui se passe
mais
j'arrête pas d'actualiser la page pour
corriger le score
j'espère que ça va changer quoi
il y a des blagues là sur
[Musique]
les blancs qui a perdu qui a une tour de
monde dans la partie là je vois que sur
le
peut-être les erreurs cheescom ou les
les parties sont pas forcément bonnes
peut-être que Jules peut-être que Jules
ici
il a tu vois peut-être que par exemple
tu as le 6 c'est martiaux contre gamer
pas la caméra on peut pas savoir si vous
voulez c'est ça la différence si on
avait eu la Camara on peut regarder on
verra la position finale je pense c'est
non parce que la joie martyrison qui a
battu gamer sur tous result et là dans
le dans le dans le dans le cheesecom
c'est c'est gamer qui a gagné Clément
donc qu'est-ce que c'est chiascom ou
est-ce que cette chaise résulte
qu'on a regardé une partie moi je pense
que c'est comme parce que tu te réserves
quand même ils sont pas enfin à moins
que ça habite tous des manchots
je vois pas trop
bien vibré on a dit partie magnifique
Jules en feu etc
on peut mettre le lien de chasse
résultat sur
si vous voulez regarder tu le mets moi
je le mets sans souci
je peux vous montrer aussi ce que nous
on voit regardez le tableau il est ici
et du coup on voit que Jul a perdu on
voit que
que darda table 11 a gagné et on voit
c'est plus le troisième c'était qui
c'était j'avais vu
un adresse résultat
donc on atteint un tableau 5 table 6
après je sais pas un carwana qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait
où il a bien perdu sur les deux sont les
deux sites c'est horrible donc voilà je
sais pas trop
on sait pas si les erreurs parce que
peut-être que ils sont inversé les
échiquiers vous savez c'est possible par
exemple je sais pas moi par rapport aux
caméras par rapport à tout ça et ben ils
ont changé l'ordre des chéquiers sur
dans tournoi vous voyez et changer
l'ordre dans le tournoi ça va changer
toutes les tables chez nous donc ça peut
être ça ou ça peut être vraiment que que
l'arbitre il a mal dormi ou peut-être
que il a sa petite bouteille à côté
cachée on sait pas ce qui se passe
l'arbitre s'est trompé c'est sauf qu'il
va y aller il va aller au Kazakhstan
corriger tout ça du coup on a des
erreurs on sait pas on sait pas d'où
ça arrive
bon comme on sait pas trop je propose
qu'on parle de choses sérieuses sauf la
quincaillerie tu nous en a pas parlé
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il y en a pas
mal qui attendent des nouvelles par
rapport à tout cela
j'ai pas avancé à sur la question pour
l'instant donc
ça fait un petit peu mais j'étais obligé
pour nos vieword d'en parler d'en parler
ça fait partie du jeu
hier je suis pas je suis pas allé dans
le pyjama alors je suis pas non plus
aller au carrefour hier bien joué Torin
mais tu sais que tu sais que je voulais
je voulais l'acheter j'aurais dû
l'acheter c'est ouf parce que j'ai je te
promets j'ai failli l'acheter et
lendemain c'est pas de métal qui dit oui
le plus jeune Pikachu quoi et j'ai
failli d'acheter la veille quoi
qu'il aurait marqué sur le chat et après
la pause je reviens avec le pilule
Pikachu juste ça aurait été sans être
génial
logique qui nous met
le lien du site officiel qui met que
effectivement Yann Christophe Douda
aurait battu
même sur le site officiel
j'ai peur que que les parties soient un
petit peu en plus c'est bizarre un truc
il y a juste un truc qui est bizarre
sauf c'est que Douda c'est pas trop le
style de la maison je veux l'hippopotame
quand même il est plutôt sérieux tu vois
bon sérieux et puis tu le sais
IE
les apparements sortent pas au moins on
aurait plus de certitudes si vous voulez
dès qu'on aura les appareils
je sais pas quoi vous dire je vais
lancer absolument rien c'est
un placement la caméra
si le 2
dans le résumé mais en cliquant sur la
partie ça marque 1 0 oui mais en fait
l'idée je pense qu'il y a il y a deux
choses soit les arbitres sont des
manchots ce que je ne pense pas quand
même c'est quand même un gros tournoi
etc je pense pas soit ce qu'il est
possible c'est qu'en fait les arbitres
échanger si vous voulez
les numéros de table par exemple une fin
il y a un échec qui est qui peut être
table 1 du coup en fait pour pour les
aider et ben ça a changé tous les noms
si vous voulez par exemple je sais pas
moi je change la table 3 et 4 d'ordre
vous voyez
et ben alors que tard lui il le sait pas
que ça a changé de joueur donc peut-être
que c'est ça du coup les joueurs en
français peut-être que la partie qui est
je sais pas gamer d'arriverian peut-être
que c'est Moussa qui a joué ici à la
place de ce genre là tu vois peut-être
qu'ils ont inversé des joueurs mais on
va voir c'est vrai que pour tout vous
dire moi j'adore l'interface il y en a
qui je sais qui aime beaucoup moins mais
par contre pour les stream j'avais déjà
fait une remontée à 5000 d'ailleurs
des fois sur les tables c'est vrai qu'on
a tout toutes les tables successivement
etc et selon les tournois il pourrait y
avoir des petites catégories ça pourrait
être un petit peu plus facile de gérer
cela et il peut y avoir des boulettes
sur chaise comme aussi
donc on est vraiment perturbé avec tout
ça
on va voir on va voir et le prochain
événement qu'on va couvrir sur chaise
comme fr après celui-ci je trouve tu es
toujours plus au courant que moi
est-ce que tu sais un petit peu il y a
des nouveaux événements qui vont arriver
nous demande techno il y aura le tata
style je pense peut-être
un petit 2 secondes avant de te répondre
à ça on voit bien que sur le que sur le
chat resold
jules a bien perdu il a parié un tableau
14 avec 9 ans
là vous le fait vous le voyez tous hein
je pense c'est quasi sûr donc bah oui je
pense que c'est cheesecom qui buggeait
ou les arbits qui ont interverti les
tables et je pense que on a on a vu une
partie qui s'est joué mais c'était pas
la partie de Jules quoi
dommage on y a cru hein
on voyait Jul en caméra bah non et qui a
bien gagné pour le coup donc il passe à
9 et demi avec une table 6
la blague pour pas de métal pas de métal
va nous chambrer
donc en belge devant tous nos
représentants tricolores c'est ça fait
mal ça fait mal pour pour notre belle
français chicane il va falloir terminer
devant Dardar on a pas le choix sinon
pas il va chanter dans le chat donc là
donc là
quand même
on a plein de parties
into contre
Naka Artémis
et donc deux grosses parties puis on a
aussi bien sûr derrière tout bof qui a
10 et demi donc à seulement un demi
point des leaders qui joue contre
martyrie océan et on a aussi un Krishna
contre Guiri qui a aussi 10 et demi donc
là on a quand même une course à 4
joueurs qui est vraiment acharné
5 encore il y a des dix points fédoc
c'est pas ridicule loin de là et ils
peuvent se mêler aussi ils sont qu'à un
point de retard par rapport à Magnus et
Hikaru donc là ça va être très très
chaud sur les cinq premières étapes tout
le monde peut encore gagner il reste du
temps on est à la 15e ronde qui arrive
il y a 21 rondes ça va être très très
chaud
ben ouais en fait c'était vraiment
émotionnel on pensait qu'il avait gagné
c'était qu'il avait gagné on avait vu la
partie de la massacrer bon pour nous
c'était cet effet mais apparemment on
s'est fait avoir avec avec l'affichage
cheesecom on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
et les parties qui sont mél c'était
vraiment quelque chose de d'accès
extraordinaire
dans tous les cas dans tous les cas on
va voir un petit peu un VL contre qui
joue et il joue contre prana va quand
même 500
il est hors course il va finir le
tournoi en roue libre donc Sébastien
joue en 267 un mètre file
pas mieux Seb il m'accuse un peu le coup
là il faut aussi proprement là il faut
gagner
c'est dur quand vous enchaînez les
boules bulles même si vous êtes grand
maître ben vous jouez toujours des
joueurs tout à fait corrects et là c'est
bon enchaîné deux nuls et 4 défaites bon
c'est c'est très dur il a pas eu des
appareils là il venait de d'enchaîner
deux bulles 3D fêtes il joue safenko qui
a un grand maître à 2600 globalement
c'est le genre de d'histoire vraiment
pas facile à gérer clairement
je sais pas c'est cadence de toute façon
à ça il le savait il est capable sur une
partie d'inquiéter n'importe qui
mais sur le long terme on sait que c'est
un joueur qui voit à peu près 2450 2500
sur cette cadence là 25 50 peut-être
quand il est quand il est au mieux et du
coup là il sous-performe légèrement
sable dans ce tournoi
donc il y a quand même quelqu'un qui a
fait une super partie même si c'est pas
Jul oui c'est pas qui c'est du coup
en tout cas
pas de métal nous fait des petites
danses dans les chats il est en train de
commencer à nous charrier
attention pas de métal je sais pas si tu
as vu le titre de l'équipe en 2018 mais
ça sent le seul à la fin je fais une
petite référence à la Une de l'équipe
on avait été quelque peu chauvin et
chambreurs pour nos voisins belges mais
cette année on a on n'a pas réussi à le
faire jusqu'au bout
du coup je vais changer le score parce
que du coup j'ai mis que
j'ai mis
alors pose la question maximale n'hésite
pas
Maximus tu peux y aller je vais juste un
truc
ouais alors on va changer on a la
question de Maximus à laquelle on va
devoir répondre et du coup les
événements de chascom tu sais un petit
peu tout à l'heure j'ai failli te poser
la question
ben écoute je sais pas j'ai entendu dire
que peut-être qu'on allait faire alors
le tata style tu sais qu'on a fait
l'année dernière
mais j'ai pas eu de nouvelles on sait
pas trop grand c'était souvent on a les
infos c'est en janvier tu peux nous
donner les dates à peu près sauf c'est
les mi-janvier à partir du mise en vie
ouais mais je sais plus j'ai pas
exactement les dates donc je ne sais pas
je vous propose qu'on regarde un petit
peu une partie du top niveau est-ce que
ça vous va si on regarde un petit quart
de scène népo pour changer un petit peu
tu me mets l'eau à la bouche sauf c'est
c'est ce que j'aurais voulu à titre
perso
parce que là jules a pris un petit peu
de plomb dans l'aile on va le laisser
tranquille on la poisse et tout à
l'heure pas la peine de le repousser
puisque je dis ça on a cru qu'il avait
gagné alors que pas du tout et ça c'est
un peu la loose avec goproquin Maximus
alors la question
[Musique]
en fait oui si les joueurs te jouent pas
la ligne que imposées dans le dans la
vidéo
très souvent ce qui proposait c'est
enfin ce que j'en vends de l'eau c'est
c'est mauvais par exemple normalement si
si les joueurs ne prennent pas le pion
en 4 par exemple si les joueurs ne
prennent pas le centre en fait et ben
juste tu vois les écraser en prenant le
centre toi-même en fait tout simplement
c'est pas si facile en pratique pour les
joueurs débutants amateurs
de réfuter une ligne qui n'est pas
théorique en fait mais ce que je trouve
propose c'est de se référer au jeu
simple et au respect des principes mais
en pratique ce qui va être simple pour
nous mettre un peu de temps de votre
côté c'est à dire que on a l'habitude
nous depuis tout petit axe trouve de
jouer différentes ouvertures il y a
certaines analogies certaines
redondances et on peut comprendre que ça
soit un peu galère de réfuter un mauvais
coup de l'adversaire c'est votre
expérience de jeu qui va vous permettre
de vous améliorer sur ce sujet là mais
c'est quand même important à terme de
bien connaître ses ouvertures parce que
plus vous allez en jouer sur le même sur
la même thématique plus vous allez
comprendre comment justement réfuter les
mauvais coups voilà c'est ça mais de
manière générale voilà là c'est en fait
c'est un grand bi dans lequel on joue
vraiment pour le centre et pour
l'initiative alors si les joueurs jouent
des coupes bizarres qui sont pas dans la
vidéo l'idée c'est juste généralement de
pousser le centre et de gagner en fait
le combat du centre donc c'est c'est là
vraiment que que se passe toute la
stratégie de l'ouverture donc développer
les pièces prendre le centre et surtout
essayer de de prendre les pièces en
gagnant l'initiative tu vois donc tu
prends le centre en attaquant par
exemple le foot c'est simple tu fais
Descartes par exemple ou enfin essaye en
fait de vite ouvrir la position pendant
que l'adversaire est bon du coup n'est
pas prêt
et du coup oui c'est plutôt la mise en
oeuvre générale de l'initiative aux
échecs dès l'ouverture qu'un sujet très
très important pour pour les amateurs
mais oui c'est pas facile et sachez que
que ça soit la Maxence ou d'autres
ouvertures c'est pas une vidéo YouTube
qui va vous permettre de tout comprendre
c'est la vidéo plus votre expérience de
jeu qui doit être très forte et même
peut-être d'autres vidéos peut-être des
écrits en plus bref il va falloir
regarder la vidéo jouer des parties
re-regarder la vidéo et analyser vos
parties c'est vraiment plusieurs choses
qui vont permettre à une sorte de chaîne
assez vertueuse pour que vous soyez
compétent sur l'ouverture ça prend
énormément de temps l'étude du jeu
d'échec vous le savez normalement et ça
se fera pas tout de suite des fois
d'ailleurs quand vous apprenez une
nouvelle ouverture ça se passe mal et
vous avez l'impression qu'il faut
l'acheter à la poubelle pas forcément si
l'ouverture est conseillée il va falloir
insister c'est vous qui ne la comprenez
pas encore suffisamment il va falloir
aller plus loin
après c'est pas c'est pas évident
justement hier j'étais avec une élève
qui avec laquelle on a travaillé
avec les Noirs contre la lapine vous
savez la lapine 4 c'est 5 C3 et il est
position sont pas évidentes on joue des
fois avec des pions isolés des fois
enfin c'est des positions ou souvent en
plus les blancs arrivent à avoir un peu
d'attaque et mais du coup les positions
sont pas forcément évidentes à jouer
pour les Noirs en pratique et du coup
c'était pas pas si clair dans la partie
a été gagnée mais c'était ça a été
laborieux
donc
les positions des fois qui sont pas
faciles à jouer donc on s'en va essayer
de comprendre ce que vous faites c'est
important pour moi c'est moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup en fait dans
l'apprentissage des ouvertures c'est pas
à prendre par coeur parce que le Parker
ça sert à rien c'est vraiment de
comprendre ce que vous faites dans votre
voiture si vous arrivez à comprendre ce
que vous faites mais vous en avez
toujours à vous sortir de toutes les
positions par exemple la question de
Maximus dans l'ouverture oui c'est
l'adversaire je passe joue pas bien etc
bah écoute enfin juste tu fais tu
appliques les principes normaux ne
sortaient pièce tu prends le centre etc
enfin vous voyez plein de trucs normaux
quoi en fait
je tousse je trouve que vous avez très
bien relayé par écrit ce qu'on a dit à
l'oral
et maintenant on va falloir le faire
concrètement sur l'échiquier mais c'est
très très bien ce que vous avez écrit je
pense clairement je comprends tout on
est tous d'accord et après la
réalisation de ce que vous avez écrit
ben ça prend des années à s'acquérir
comme nous le faisons remarquer mais
endertale de manière rigolote mais oui
c'est c'est pas c'est pas instantané
l'acquisition forcément donc après il y
a un lien de Pocket fridge sur ouais
voilà how to get force a Starcraft to
ok moi je connais rien Instagram mais
après voilà c'est c'est le même genre
comme tu dis tu vois il y a beaucoup de
fois les règles tu as un jeu stratégique
peut peut s'appliquer à d'autres jeux
donc clairement clairement encourageant
ton message Hervé 7b qui nous dit on
veut revenir la partie là nous faire
remarquer qu'on n'a pas dit grand chose
alors déjà attention les temps c'est pas
9 secondes je pense pour Magnus et une
minute 30 et au-delà de ça on voit une
domination pour moi de népot depuis le
début de la partie puisque le fou des 6
est enterré le fou noir de Magnus est
enterré mais ça reste solide ouais j'ai
pas aimé le f55
vous voyez juste un peu
stouf exactement bah j'ai pensé quand il
est en fait quand on joue F5 très
souvent après la prise on donne toutes
les cases blanches à l'adversaire donc
vous voyez il a ramené la dame la tour
le cavalier qui vient 4 et il y a plus
moyen de virer en fait ce cavalier donc
je trouve ça un petit peu dommage mais
après bon on va pas critiquer il coûte
45 c'est
il y a sûrement quelque chose que que
nous on ne comprend pas peut-être mais
F5 c'était un coup qui moi m'a un petit
peu choqué on me dit que c'est bien un
six secondes qu'aurait Magnus est-ce
qu'on peut avoir l'autre vue avec
l'échiquier en petit et le grand angle
sur les joueurs ouais allez hop c'est
parti et je crois que il a l'air de pas
pour il regarde pas mal sa pendule
effectivement donc je pense que Alex a
raison
on va pas bien malheureusement
effectivement on voit on voit que
carlossen est en grand the note
[Musique]
pas bien avoir le temps sur la caméra
ouais moi je peux te dire qu'il a moins
de 10 secondes c'est certain et le donc
les scores les temps sont fiables
merci Alex
bah on perd on perd la partie qu'on a
plus de temps courgette donc le temps
c'est aussi important que le reste
on est dans le cheval du monde de Blitz
qui correspond à la cadence la plus
courte aux échecs
alors avantage pour le cavalier blanc
qui domine la position mais Magnus n'a
pas dit son dernier mot
pour conclure cavalier avoir des
attaques à découvertes
et qui est tombé il est tombé il est
tombé il est tombé les plus de temps à
la pendule car celle qui perd autant
ouais mais c'était pas clair en fait on
va on va pas bien la pendule quand même
j'ai du mal à voir avec cette villa
peut-être que la vue vraiment en grande
complètement
arrangé les pièces de dépôt alors je
rappelle qu'aux échecs normalement c'est
pas le perdant qui range les pièces
c'est juste que quand
est plus élégant sur ce registre là que
connait pas ça dépend des jours
en tout cas il est possible que n'a qu'à
perdre aussi
qui peut perdre aussi contre un très
bien et personne qui sait en difficulté
en tout cas
il est trop de partout
ça va être gagné regardez belle victoire
d'artemief la rigueur russe
punaise là c'est
le tournoi qui est complètement relancé
avec les deux favoris qui perdent en
même temps et tandis que guéri bon
attends je vais pas regarder les
résultats
pour pas dire de bêtises mais les
poursuivants guiris du bof
résultats honnêtement je te le dis on
voit double qui a perdu aussi d'ailleurs
contre marseillais aux gens
les trois trois parce que faisait partie
des joueurs des joueurs en tête guili
qui a fait nul qui rejoint 45 et
enaka et on avait encore un joueur je
crois non à
quoi ça fait nul comme on a un scène et
guéri les trois en tête et vous assistez
aussi à la partie chez les féminines on
va voir tan s'imposer contre gorillage
qui n'a qui va abandonner voilà
qui est à droite qui est championne du
monde de rapides
et grillage qui n'a la jeune la jeune
Russe qui est quasiment 2600 hello feed
et
qui est jeune en plus qui a quel âge a
le droit de 18h puisque c'était la
grande rivale dans les catégories jeunes
de français 18 ans alors
[Musique]
j'aurais dit 20 ans mais bon tu vois
quelque chose comme ça une vingtaine
d'années qui qui est vraiment très
prometteuse
[Musique]
donc là on a une partie là
c'est celle de rigazie qui vient de
battre burzin
mais ça reste assez ouvert
complètement alors Jules on va regarder
ce qu'il a fait mais là je vois pas on a
eu une petite blague de de comment dire
de tout à l'heure donc Jules qui
apparemment ici aurait gagné mais bon
[Musique]
encore une fois
il faut qu'on regarde peut-être parce
que l'un des surprises
[Musique]
en tout cas si il a gagné il peut être
relancé aussi avec 10 points
donc là on voit la caméra à Christiane
scène qui a qui allait noir
si on voit un petit Christian de scène
contre
Ivic la paire de fou elle est
ce qu'elle va suffire avec le pion h
en bas en tout petit il évite du coup
qui qui a les blancs avec deux fous pour
la dame
qui était tenté si on fait F5 il y a
peut-être un chèque
qu'on fait fouger 6
c'est très chaud
alors là il y a ça va très vite sur mon
étiquet ça ne bouge pas je regarde sur
je regarde sur la cam
pas mal malheureusement
avec tout ça
ils ont plus de temps les joueurs ils
ont trois secondes chacun il faut
contrôler la poussée du pion H qui est
très très bien fait par le joueur noir
il avance son roi et il devrait gagner
si il se prend pas de sale coup
le roi qui rend avance dangereusement
et le pion le pionceau qui est perdu
voilà et puis on HS qui est perdu aussi
normalement
pour les noirs on va promouvoir le pion
des faut faire un peu gaffe
attention à mes chèques il y avait
et c'est l'abandon
travail Christian and 5 qui est qui est
compagnon d'équipe de quinzaine aux
Olympiades
oui bien sûr courgette tu tu joues et
appuies sur la pendule de la même main
c'est obligatoire justement de jouer
d'une main et appuyer de l'autre main
c'est considéré comme un coup comme un
coup illégal
considéré donc je peux réclamer à
l'arbitre le coup illégal
donc faire attention à ce genre de trucs
à ce niveau-là les joueurs le savent et
et
on joue dans le prolongement en fait on
appuie dans le prolongement du coup que
l'on joue
je sais pas je pense qu'il y a eu un
problème de
un problème de
de compatibilité des chéquiers c'était
pas la bonne partie enfin c'était pas
les bons joueurs tout à l'heure alors
que je la bien battu par avion par
contre c'est pas un coup légal mais
c'est une sanction je suis pas sûr tant
pis en vrai il me semble que c'est
depuis pas longtemps qu'on sait comme
couplé les gars jouer de
appuyer de l'autre main il me semble que
c'est cool légal après bon ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas que j'ai pas
ouvert le livre de l'arbitre pour te
dire les règles évolu continuellement en
fait ça on peut le dire et pour essayer
de laisser le moins de place aux
situations ambigüe voilà c'est c'est
vraiment le sens des règles aux échecs
donc il ne manque que les résultats des
quatre premières tables sur chess
results mais on voit qu'il y a un
regroupement voilà avec donc nepo qui va
être à 11 points Magnus à 11 points
artemief à 17,5
à 11
guéri à 11
fédos et Douda aussi à 17,5
ouais je vais vous montrer tout ce qui
se passe sur sur le twitch
vous allez voir
c'est complètement incroyable au niveau
au niveau des des résultats franchement
voilà c'est du jamais vu regardez on a
je crois tout on a qu'un 11 regardez
Naka quinzaine Guiri marseillais aussi
en époque on a cinq joueurs à égalité
pour la première place et on a derrière
quatre joueurs à 10 et demi à un demi
point seulement donc on a trois Russes
Artémis
avec un surdouda qui est 6 ennemis on a
Jul qui en embuscade avec avec le jeune
Dardar le jeune patte métallier italien
et
donc ils peuvent bien sûr revenir ils
sont ils sont très très proches du
groupe du groupe de tête
et on va irrigazie quand tu l'as dit il
remonte il est à 9h30
il lui reste plein de parties
[Rires]
en plus au départage parce qu'il a un
mauvais départage on va regarder moi je
vais regarder un peu regardé ce qu'il
avait parce que il a très très mal
commencé à ce tour là et là il vient de
faire trois
victoires et deux nuls d'affilée donc
il revient après il fait pas un bon
tournoi pour l'instant donc il est voilà
et là il jouait la zavik apparemment en
plus un apparemment qui est favorable
pour lui donc il pourrait vraiment pas
mal revenir donc on va voir les
appartements si
vraiment sur ici alors aujourd'hui si
vous les voyez bien sur mon non vous les
voyez pas bien il faut que je mette
comme ça faut que je l'affiche bien
voilà donc là on voit 45e heure donc la
partie du départage qui aurait pu avoir
lieu
pour les rapides on voit guirinerpo
martyrio et Nakamura qui relégué à la 4e
table contre grishook c'est pas vraiment
un bon appareil pour pour Naka hein
Kevin c'est pas facile je trouve parce
qu'on a pas trop vu grisho mais on sait
que c'est un très bon blitzer maintenant
les joueurs vont aller chercher loin
leurs adversaires je parle de Magnus et
de Hikaru qui ont joué quasiment tous
les joueurs du groupe de tête donc ils
vont chercher un peu plus loin les
joueurs Kemer a 10 points grishoka 10
points et ça va être comme ça maintenant
jusqu'à la fin du tournoi si Jules
venait à gagner il peut jouer soit il
carou soit Magnus c'est tout le mal
qu'on lui souhaite à Jules c'est ça
alors gagne il faut dire que
l'adversaire de Naka gris tchouks il est
double champion du monde de Blitz donc
c'est c'est pas du tout un débile dans
bon aux échecs et encore plus en blitz
donc les notes en règle générale donc il
est malin quand même à cette cadence là
qui comprend bien les échecs qui
rentrent très très fort aux échecs qui a
été
pendant très longtemps 2800 Elo et
pas loin et donc Naka qui fasse
attention parce que quelque chose c'est
vraiment la dernière fois qu'il peut lui
poser problème
ensuite bon Martini aussi tu vois tout à
l'heure enfin on en a parlé hier qu'il
fallait qu'il fasse ses preuves parce
que ok il a 27 45 emblite
voilà mais là clairement il est il fait
partie d'un groupe de stars si on peut
dire ou autant de lui il y a que des
joueurs qui sont dans le top dans le top
30 mondial alors que lui voilà
donc
hier donc tu m'en parlais en me disant
bah voilà Kevin c'est un super joueur
sur Internet et tout ça et on a plein
quand même dans le tournoi qui sont très
bons sur Internet et on voit quand en
réel il s'écroule un petit peu enfin il
prouve pas leur îlot de 3000 sur chess
com il prouve pas qu'ils sont non plus
dans les 10 premières tables ce joueur
Marty rosian maintenant il a tout le
temps été dans les premières tables
depuis un moment en tout cas
et du coup ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
arrive à tenir tête effectivement comme
tu le dises tout au meilleur joueur donc
maintenant on va voir si si il continue
mais en tout cas il a très bien confirmé
je dois hyper hyper dangereux en cadence
rapide et on doit aussi mais Elite
mondial en cadence rapide Elite
officiel lent il est quand même à 2006
80 donc c'est pas non plus le plot tu
vois c'est pas un joueur à 2005-2006
qui est là par hasard tu vois c'est un
genre qui m'aime au vrai échec bah il
est quand même là quoi tu vois c'est un
quand même un quasiment 2007 donc c'est
vraiment un jeune qui monte qui qui
a un
très très beau futur et on va au stade
le 7 Jules contre André Keane donc André
King joueur très solide très sérieux et
Jules ouais donc on va regarder je pense
la partie peut-être de de Jules
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Kevin ouais
super là il est remonté ça nous fait
plaisir d'aller le voir et
petite remarque il y a merci à Gaïa et
Templiers et ont été dans le livre de
l'arbitre peut-être que tambier est
arbitre aussi en tout cas Gaïa j'en suis
certain et elle est allé voir tout comme
templier le livre de l'arbitre pour nous
dire que c'est pas vraiment un coup
illégal le fait ou pas du tout un coup
illégal d'appuyer avec la mauvaise main
par contre on peut avoir un
avertissement ce qui est logique aussi
dans ces cas là merci à vous alors ça
fait très longtemps que j'ai pas suivi
tout ça
et heureusement qu'on a des arbitres
avec nous merci à vous
pas compris trop loin pour moi non plus
je sais pas tout il parle alors Robinson
d'ailleurs on a eu des pas mal de bugs
tout à l'heure avec cheesecom bon je
sais que toi tu c'est un peu régulé tu
peux pas tu peux pas mais en fait on a
eu par exemple la partie de Jules on a
suivi la partie de Jul contre Douda
table 5 et Jules
masterclass de Jules contre Moussard et
donc on a commenté on était hyper chaud
et tout puis à la fin on a vu quelque
chose révolte et ben c'était pas du tout
pas du tout le bon enfin
la bonne partie parce que Jules avait
perdu en fait parce que nous on a vu
gagner en direct et on arrive sur le
site officiel qui disait aussi que que
Jules avait perdu mais que voilà donc il
y a eu des plein de résultats comme ça
donc je pense que il y a eu un kit
bizarre ouais
apparemment cet événement
ok donc pour les plaintes évidemment
vous adresser directement à robinside
voilà ça lui fera plaisir
j'ai vu mais bon c'est un fond marron
malheureusement voilà vous avez
qu'est-ce comme m'impose le fond de
l'échiquier avec les pièces la couleur
etc
moi généralement j'aime me mettre le
bleu
mais voilà donc on a tous nos petits toc
moi j'aime bien l'échiquier tradi je
crois que c'est érable je sais pas stouf
c'est des pièces qui sont plus des cases
qui sont un peu plus marron clair un peu
les chicaston quoi tu vois
moi j'aime bien un truc un peu bleu tu
vois bleu clair
les joueurs fantasmes
et le Stanton ça a été une évolution
donc si je peux l'avoir sur internet je
suis déjà hyper content quoi après
j'avoue quand j'ai lu quand j'ai
commencé des cités bleus à j'étais en
Argentine et ça faisait vachement tu
vois à côté Argentine mais depuis le
match contre la France je sais pas si je
reviens comme ça un peu plus on peut
plus on peut plus
déjà mais s'il a il a intérêt de gagner
avec des Champions avec Paris pour se
faire un peu oublier voilà
parce que là là ça fait trop mal
alors je vais vous changer le score
le score donc on a Jules qui la 7 sur 4
914 on a Jul qui a 9 sur 15 du coup sur
mvl excusez-moi je trou de mémoire
MDL il a battu prana donc ça lui fait un
petit 8 sur 15 et on n'a pas suivi
d'ailleurs Sébastien Mazet lors de cette
rencontre
à ta situation à ta citation pardon
gritchouk c'est pas un débile voilà la
pointe de Robinson
demande aussi à robinside l'adresse et
de ses avocats pour les plaintes
éventuelles voilà n'endertale toujours
aussi passé sur le chat
est-ce que c'est courant les joueurs qui
sont meilleurs en physique qu'en ligne
ah oui il y en a plein
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui sont
meilleurs en physique qu'en ligne ou
meilleur qu'en ligne qu'en physique vous
avez tout vous avez le joueur qui est
habitué aux 2D d'autres qui sont
habitués aux 3D et en fait ben c'est pas
la même chose les prêts à l'aise avec la
souris et qui prévaut
une partie la partie de de ce fameux
entre-temps qui a perdu autant dans la
fenêtre de dames tu te souviens là et il
a joué avec une seconde à la pendule il
est tombé et en fait
sur internet avec une seconde il joue 40
coups quoi
et là il est tombé et pourtant il a
juste en quoi avec une seconde mais je
pense qu'en fait pour lui on l'avait
même vu aussi à l'époque il y a quelques
années à lire les raisins ferroja je
veux qu'on regarde
dès qu'il joue un coup en direct à
chaque prise vous êtes tombé deux pièces
et du coup ça a énervé cartienne tu vois
genre c'est bon quoi tu vois et en fait
tu as l'impression que c'est un manchot
quoi continue des pièces parce qu'en
fait il y avait le confinement il y
avait tout ça et puis c'est vrai que les
raisins c'est un gros joueur d'Internet
et donc oui il y a des différences entre
entre tout ça il y a des joueurs aussi
on peut même le voir sur sur tiascom des
joueurs qui ont des niveaux modestes qui
ont des très gros élodos sur James com
donc
voilà tu as même des maîtres qui ont
3000 3100 hello sur tscom je pense que
c'est tu l'aimais
tournoi comme ici par exemple il serait
voilà il serait pas là quoi enfin en
tout cas il n'existerait pas et mais bon
il y a aussi beaucoup de skill à la
souris et puis et puis autre chose quoi
donc après encore une fois si son maître
Fides et qu'ils ont 3100 et d'eau c'est
quand même aussi que qu'il y a une
raison quoi parce que normalement 3100
et l'autre tu es quand même
un petit grand maître ou un bon ami quoi
tu vois enfin tout à fait
de tous les temps
j'adorais je la et je trouve que Carlson
aujourd'hui vulgarise le haut niveau
avec des conceptions simples donc je
suis grand fan et toi souffle moi je te
dirai tal
castorrovenceuk et Carsen
parce que j'ai du mal à décider mais
c'est vrai que carcennes en fait ce qui
fait actuellement c'est juste la folie
et kaspora dans son temps c'était un peu
la même chose mais à son niveau et ils
vont en dessous parce qu'il est il est
c'est un énorme génie et
j'adore tout ce qui fait aussi donc
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant alors
c'est reparti visiblement tout je vous
ai mis pour l'instant je vous ai mis ça
excusez-moi je suis un petit peu et on
voulait voir du coup la partie de Jules
on avait dit donc je sais pas la cam sur
le jules Jules couteau 7
mais en tout cas on a la mix cam
pour l'instant et
Jules qui joue une sorte de Gambut d'âme
tranquille solide et voir un peu ce qui
se passe contre André Kim
donc en régime qui a joué d'ailleurs qui
a participé au speech
en 200700 20 30 depuis qu'il est né non
c'est pas un cadeau mais bon avec 10
points il faut il faut commencer à jouer
l'effort sinon
on s'en sort plus manger a mis ses
pièces de façon bizarre parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un gamin
m'accepté ou le cavalier B1 n'est pas
très performant des deux alors
on sait pas il a pas envie on a pas de
nouvelles malheureusement
des Swatch you watching
parce que je pense qu'il faut pas jouer
avec une structure à 6 B5 mais plutôt B6
rouba 7 parce que sur A6 B5 il y aurait
eu A4 et on gagne la case C4 bon même là
A4 bon V6 direct était normal bon ça
change pas grand chose peut-être voilà
on n'a pas obtenu grand chose régler
blanc on va jouer aux échecs
je pense à ce niveau là c'est pas la
prépa qui va forcément jouer c'est aussi
le style de jouer vite de exactement ta
pression aussi on parlait beaucoup de
mettre la pression au temps et de
découvrir complètement
[Musique]
en tout cas Jules qui est bien placé
dans cette tournoi et qui pourrait
vraiment
faire un exploit dans championnat du
monde
chouchou il est pas en forme mvl on a un
peu oublié là on l'a laissé un petit peu
de côté parce que il est trop loin
maintenant dans ce tournoi et il aura
pas bien défendu son titre il était bien
parti hein il a un petit peu un petit
peu craqué bah écoutez c'est un joueur
de très très haut niveau d'un immense
talent mais qui a une période où il est
un peu moins en forme que d'habitude et
du coup ça se voit parce que d'habitude
justement il nous habitué à des à des
grands résultats mais il va se refaire
il va revenir il faut qu'on soit
confiant
c'est des choix de joueurs un crédit
Maxime Lagarde il était présent je sais
pas d'Europe il y a peu mais il fait pas
ce cheval du monde je pense qu'il y a
les fêtes je crois qu'il joue tour si
mais en partie lente c'est pas tout à
fait le même le même standing
mais il fallait aller au Kazakhstan il
fallait s'organiser
ça pouvait être à sa charge aussi parce
que pas de sponsor pas de pas
d'invitation fédérale à ma connaissance
sur ce type de tournoi donc
c'est pas si facile que ça il pouvait
même être négatif au final dans ce type
de tournoi donc c'est des choix
au-delà du choix sportif il y a le choix
pécunier et il y en a qui préfèrent
jouer en partie lente
il est un peu passif pour l'instant
au niveau des pièces mineures le
cavalier F1 il fait un peu peine à voir
le cadre bien échiquier j'aime beaucoup
la fonction des Noirs ici
[Musique]
pas si facile comment il va s'en sortir
Jules pour rééquilibrer la position fous
des câbles mon cou pour faire cadrer des
deux sans doute pour ressortir les
pièces
si vous n'aimez pas vos pièces
échangez-les contre les bonnes pièces
adverses c'est un conseil qu'on peut
toujours donner
en tout cas notre niveau bien sûr ceux
qui sont très proches de Maxime doivent
le savoir mais en tout cas nous avec
avec tout on n'avait pas les infos OK
mais au moins ça a pas fini en trois
coups comme avec
comme avec avec Naka
qui
qui a pas fait nulle
[Musique]
la cadence
et là on se fait un petit peu embêté
dans le milieu de jeu la paire de fou
c'est du coup une sorte de Demi pion
d'avance si vous voulez pour
enregkin une fourchette qui peut arriver
aussi en C3 attention
alors peut-être fou des cinq peut-être
sur le coup parce que attention la
fourchette sur la découverte juste
cavalier C3 je pense tac interception tu
pourrais
c'est compliqué je peux pas sur échec
mais après j'ai madame en prise et quand
je la bouche je perds là et je peux pas
attaquer le cavaler ces trois ça va
gagner une pièce il me semble
il faut qu'il trouve fou des cinq parce
que ça attaque le fou baissé entre moi
mais c'est et là il va y avoir qu'à
essai 3 c'est sûr
il y a plein de de tactique là mais ça
va très vite pour avoir un peu je pense
il a pris ses trois donc du coup c'est
terminé grande difficulté pour Jules qui
va essayer d'arnaquer mais le problème
c'est qu'il a 7 secondes contre 58
secondes donc énorme partie d'endriking
qui a simplement amélioré toutes ces
pièces et il a trouvé de meilleures
cases que Jules qui a conduit Jules à
devoir faire trop de concessions
donc facile à dire facile à observer
mais très difficile de jouer
ça a l'air ça a l'air finir cette
position
est-ce qu'on va voir
parce que là
il va perdre
on va essayer parce qu'en blé de ça il
faut qu'on aille vite malheureusement
pas rester trop longtemps car c'est qui
apparemment est gagnant après roi H7 qui
va dépendre des trois et puis on prend
des trois
qui range les pièces et qui a gagné la
partie
[Musique]
la caméra
mais en fait il vous tableau 7 on a que
4 caméras en fait jouer sur donc est-ce
que Naka va faire tomber grishouk dans
ses positions en posant des problèmes
déjà d'un seul c'est un petit coup
c'est un peu un peu passif donc ils sont
très peu de temps peut-être vous mettre
la je vous mettre la grande vue la vue
on voit où on voit tout pression
je vous mets la vie avec le grand
fichier qui est il vient jouer trop de
dernier coup il est complètement rentré
dans la position de grid show qui a
perdu en un coup ici tout reprend ça de
regarder la combinaison avec la
prochaine royale derrière
[Musique]
abandon qui fait que sur tout reprend F7
et ben on a cavalier prend
E60
mais le fait est que dans les
complications en jouant très rapidement
il met une pression au temps et il gagne
avec ça terrible
c'est un peu bateau mais ça passe
oui bien sûr Alex c'est très bien dit
régularité et constant et ça suffit
oui plus aussi fort qu'avant zainote
néerland je suis bien d'accord
on expose souvent maintenant
ouais Maxime aussi fait un peu de zèle
des fois d'accord en quittant la table
en disant ouais pas très joyeux tout ça
mais je pense qu'il était bien content
quand même il n'a pas trop montré mais
clairement après il y a beaucoup aussi
de de
pression là on arrive à la fin du
tournoi et c'est pas évident quoi je
vais vous remettre une camionnette
je vais mettre une caméra plus grande
qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste
qui fait lvl qui a batturé comme ça
bon bah c'est bien pour mvl de finir
quand même sur une note correcte
Sébastien en 2300
arménien qui vient de qui vient de
terminer contre philosophe et il a gagné
j'ai mal interprété mais il attendait
l'abandon de son adversaire en fait
c'est ça que sa tête voulait dire il a
gagné
il a remis les pièces de cf
il a fait trois sur 6 contre les grosses
stars de du championnat donc il est il
est présent mais il a perdu guéri perdu
Naka perdu
gamer il perd pas il a battu fait
dossiers du boeuf bon lasagnes
mais il a battu tous les joueurs qui ont
par contre là c'est un peu dur mais bon
tu vois il est quand même
à suivre ça doit c'est clairement pas
facile en tout cas il est à 11 point et
là on voit du rabahli à la caméra du
rabat Élie on va vous mettre la partie
de du rabahli on sait pas contre qui
joue on ne connaît pas l'adversaire
c'est ça qu'on routine le fameux tin
voilà
pas très bien classé mais très bon dans
ces cadences là
il y a un pressing blanc je trouve mais
c'est pas facile de passer il va falloir
ramener le cavalier en F8 sur échec
peut-être un moment faire dames 8 je
sais pas parce qu'il a choisi en tout
cas
il a choisi la montée folklorique du roi
le plus gros qui monte blanche ouais
si jamais c'est moi c'est moi qui joue
pour gagner
des échecs là aussi qui peuvent arriver
ça peut vite tourner dans les deux sens
j'ai mal vu sur la caméra
Fulla pour la petite échec en H4 il
aurait joué au coup d'avance c'était
peut-être très dangereux aussi le droit
se joue à almati au Kazakhstan
les blancs ce qu'on pourrait pas
balancer notre pion h pour aller gagner
et salut Arnaud je t'ai pas vu Arnaud
sur le chat bienvenue à toi et à tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent c'était chaud
le quoi une seconde
j'aurais bien joué mon pion H1 qui peut
te dire stouf on va essayer de gagner
c'est chaud aussi
tranquillement regarder la partie oh là
là c'est dur de jouer ce coup-là
il y avait il y avait de la meuf 3 et
chaque suivi
dame G2 ouf
des deux joueurs ça va tomber
il est tombé
jouait cavalier H4 dame prend H4
il est parti avec son roi il a pris tous
les risques possibles du rabat Élie et
du coup bah il s'est engouffrer dans un
dans un seul jeu
mais il a serré la main de son
adversaire bon il jouait pour pour pas
grand chose de toute façon mais c'est un
[Musique]
ultra Bullet de haut niveau à la fin
avec des tentatives des deux joueurs les
deux joueurs qui ont des jouets des
coups à une seconde Doura Baily qui a
fini par donner sa pendule après encore
une fois il y a beaucoup de pression
donc des fois juste voilà dès que tu
perds bon c'est pas forcément que les
gens sont pas faire play ou autre mais
voilà c'est quelque chose qui c'est des
réactions qui qui peuvent être
compréhensibles sans vouloir manquer de
respect à l'adversaire
bien sûr donc là on est chez les femmes
tape 31 je le connais aucune bien
joueuse qui devrait arriver et ça a fait
nul voilà
c'est une bonne question jabbanoise je
pense qu'on avait eu des problèmes
déchiquier tout à l'heure peut-être
inversions sur des réseaux chéquiers je
vois pas d'autres explications que ça
malheureusement je n'en sais rien mais
voilà nous on est sur cheesecom il y a
eu tout un des petits bugs donc on fait
au mieux en tout cas pour vous relayer
sans flammes dans le dans le chat stuff
en vrai en vrai en vrai on est aussi
content que les joueurs belges brillent
pour moi et oui non mais on est quand
même ok
cheesecom on est on est francophone
exactement franchement on est content
quand les joueurs belges suisses
canadien on reste le chemin
complètement après voilà s'il faut le
monter dans le monde
[Rires]
on se rejoint bien là
[Musique]
il s'excusera tu vois enfin il pourra
pas parce qu'il sera modéré mais mais
il comprendra quoi il acceptera son sort
alors que elle a même la même rêve que
moi tout à l'heure j'en ai parlé de
cette une de l'équipe
Néandertal qui nous avait fait sourire
légèrement au détriment de nos copains
de nos copains belges ce qui a un match
car c'est animal car cette journée ou
pas bonne question une bonne question
était un peu à la rue dernièrement je
sais pas ce qu'il a fait dans cette
partie parce que il était à la rue mais
il était pas si grand que ça quand même
là
il a 8 et demi mais si il a gagné il
sera 9 et demi pendant 45 à 12 mois mais
il peut encore ouais
il va pouvoir peut-être avoir sa partie
contre 45 ou bien contre même n'a qu'un
je vous rappelle que les
il a fait un procès anaka aussi à
cheescom un peu à tout le monde et là je
vais vous dire en direct il vient de
perdre contre comparaté donc 8 et demi
12 ça fait quand même
foutu bon vous savez que ils vont être
obligés d'aller piocher les Naka les
Carlsen
plus en bas que leur groupe de points
parce qu'ils ont déjà joué quasiment
tout le monde 4 points
c'est beaucoup et même si remonte Niman
il n'a pas le vélo suffisant pour le
moment pour
pour être privilégié dans le fait
d'affronter Naka ou Carlsen si on peut
appeler ça un privilège en tout cas
monter les chercheurs là pour l'instant
animal dans la dans la partie numéro 17
il a il a quatre points de retard
quasiment sur 4 scène enaka il est très
loin donc là c'est apparemment sans
sortir on a de belles affiches je vais
vous les montrer à l'écran à l'instant
regardez-moi ça boum attendez je n'ai
pas le cadré je reviens sur mon petit
chat resolt arrive et on a du coup
Caravana Carlsen avec Carola 17 12 on a
un épaule 11 et demi contre martyril qui
a 12 on a André kinakamura
c'est
Andreï parce que Naka il aura fort à
faire en drakking on vient de voir
contre Jules il a dégagé une impression
de facilité il était pas en forme en
début du tournoi il est en train de
revenir hein
clairement et on a et on a aussi bien
sûr carvana contre contre Carlson qui
est ben le match un petit peu
le gros derby depuis des années donc le
numéro 1 est de mondiaux même si ok
Caravana normalement il a il a pas une
très bonne année on va dire en 2022 mais
c'est quand même un des plus gros derby
qu'on puisse avoir dans ce monde des
échecs donc en plus hier enfin hier
c'était avant-hier d'ailleurs qui sont
genre rapides ou cartes scènes a eu pas
mal de réussite enfin sa Cabana parce
qu'il était il était très très mal il a
failli la perdre
donc on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
dans cette partie de Blitz on vous
rappelle aussi qu'au speech open ship
cars donc adopter aux échec c'est un
terme quand on met quand on gagne une
partie enfin une série de 10 parties
d'affilée contre un joueur et ben on
estime qu'on a adopté
notre adversaire donc Arthur a gagné 22
à 4 avec son adversaire voilà 22 4 avec
avec zéro défaite pour 45 c'était assez
hallucinant comme match donc là c'est du
Blitz karaté encore une fois vachement
l'ascendant psychologique mais bon ça
reste une partie car on a les blancs il
y a beaucoup à faire donc c'est
compliqué pas de métal va être content
parce que darda il joue madame minaf
alors on verra si ça suffit à darda
parce que c'est quand même le plus
faible en et l'eau dans ce groupe de
points on a vu qu'il avait battu de très
très forts joueurs et on a un
appareillement plus défavorable je pense
pour Jules Moussard qui a les pièces
noires contre Yu-Gi qui est en train de
revenir un un petit peu avec ces 10
points et qui est en obligation de
gagner pour recoller au peloton de tête
on voit que jusqu'à 10 points tout le
monde peut revenir dans la course et
même peut-être unionerguezi premier des
9 points et demi meilleur hello des 9
points et demi en dessous ça sera bien
trop dur il reste maintenant 5 secondes
donc il faut faire des grosses corps
mais quand on a 9,5 on peut encore se
permettre de rêver qu'on a notre point
comme Maxime ça va être plus dur de de
revenir dans la tête peut-être quand
même on peut on peut revenir aller en
faisant cinq sur cinq peut-être
s'approcher du podium il aura un mauvais
départage donc je pense que c'est foutu
comme on le disait tout à l'heure et
Sébastien Mazet il en est où il joue en
200300 dernière table du groupe des 7
points donc 66e table un tournoi
maintenant un peu plus confidentiel pour
pour Seb c'est ça je mets les scores
9 mvl 10 Jules et 7 Sébastien c'est les
scores qu'ils ont d'ailleurs je voulais
de mettre sur 16 sur 16 parties et donc
voilà un plein de parties intéressantes
qu'est-ce que tu veux regarder l'ordre
cette partie
là je suis je suis gêné parce que tout
est bien alors tu sais bien que j'adore
regarder cars scène donc le carwana
Carlsen est très bon et sinon il y a
André kinaka Le yumoussa est pas mal on
peut peut-être poser la question au chat
stouf parce que il y a trois pour moi
grosse affiche parmi Caruana Carlson
André kidnaka et you Moussa ce sont les
trois grosses affiches je pense de cette
ronde ouais je vais vous faire voter en
fait je vais faire une petite pause là
on va
nous mettre un petit prédiction sondage
là
et vous allez pouvoir choisir merci à
toi tout t'assurer ce lien technique
vous avez deux minutes
vous avez au-dessus du chat
les votes qui sont ouverts
quand même je donne je donne ma petite
voix
on demande au chat quand même parce que
c'est vrai que Jules c'est le genre
français qu'on a envie de suivre qui
fait un super tendance après on apprend
là on a quand même la fin du championnat
du monde qui arrive avec
avec un carbone à Carlson et on voyait
que même à 12 points on va quincennes
martylosant Nakamura mais on a aussi un
groupe à 11,5
en vrai c'est hyper hyper chaud
et
du coup
ouais l'étoile signifie que ce joueur
est assigné en acheter fixe vrai Joss
tout à fait
et affianteco qui
pendrix
je sais pas généralement généralement ça
se passe plutôt bien au niveau du son
est-ce que est-ce que le son c'est
ça pose problème que chez fiancé
dans pas longtemps avec moins de 5
minutes je pense tous les joueurs sont
en train de s'asseoir les appareils sont
sortis depuis un tout petit moment et on
voit qu'il s'attroupe pour regarder les
appareils
un filtre je vais supprimer le bruit
et moi je peux pas vous dire si tu
commandes tu pourrais faire l'accent
belge je trouve ah super il y a une idée
de Néandertal qui darda vient sur les
tables hautes je pense que je trouve
comment Trave l'accent belge c'est une
excellente idée avec ma voix ça va être
dur mais je trouve peut le faire c'est
une bonne idée
tu vois donc
j'ai fait suppression du bruit est-ce
que ça est-ce que c'est mieux ou pas
je peux je peux éloigner un peu le micro
de moi aussi en tout cas on y va du vote
moi j'avais j'avais été corpo j'ai voté
Jules mais c'est Carlson qui a remporté
le suffrage alors personne veut suivre
enfin personne si il y a 4 personnes
mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau du sondage
c'est un petit 7 % seulement pour ça a
été pas mal suivi en tout cas
j'espère j'espère que
j'espère comment on dirais-je que Maka
dans ce cas là vu que il est moins suivi
ne va pas nous faire du mal en
remportant ce championnat ce qui est pas
impossible hier après que son gros point
d'avance on se disait qu'il était quand
même très très bien placé et finalement
bah ça a été dur pour lui aujourd'hui
maintenant que tous les gros sont
affamés
parce que là c'est le moment pour les
compétiteurs
alors du coup bienvenue à toi José et
merci pour tes mots en tout cas on est
sur haut-parleur apparemment au bureau
c'est cool c'est
cools
et nous les rapides mais il était malade
il sentait pas bien et il était pas sûr
de pouvoir assurer à 100% les le splat
Blitz par rapport à sa santé donc il a
préféré
ne pas se compromettre avec l'événement
et nous laisser la place donc mais vous
inquiétez pas kevin est toujours là et
puis continuera
les tournois sur pièces cam
donc voilà le bureau ouais peut-être un
champion normal
c'est pas trop en fait au niveau de la
caisse de résonance au niveau de tout ça
en vrai je
sais pas trop après c'est vrai que
généralement la pièce je suis une pièce
qui généralement résonne quand même mais
après j'avais fait des
mois tu vois donc comme quoi selon les
selon les personnes ça peut varier dans
l'ensemble on se dit que le son était
j'avais cru comprendre aussi que
dépendamment de comment tu écoutes le
stream des fois si tu es en écouteur ou
juste en avec enceinte ou avec toi des
fois ça peut changer un petit peu de
comment
[Musique]
de comment
de Cyril nous dit que c'est le son est
parfait
pas de souci bip bip t'inquiète pas il
faut pas faut pas hésiter nous on essaie
de s'adapter avec
avec
vos commentaires voilà et le fait d'être
deux dans un stream
ça peut peut-être jouer sous j'en sais
rien en tout cas c'est peut-être la
pièce effectivement
vous allez faire acheter en plus de la
moustiquaire de stouf tu vas acheter tu
sais des mousses qu'on peut coller au
mur sauf pour absorber le les résonances
je crois que ça existe et du coup du
coup tu vas être bien la quincaillerie à
demander ça
il y a pas mal à pas mal d'idées
rien de grave te dit fiancetto
je viens de le mettre est-ce que ça va
mieux ou pas parce que du coup je sais
pas ce que c'est je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que le Christ j'en aucune idée
je me sens un truc dites-moi si ça
change ou pas
donc la partie bon commencé d'accord je
vais vous mettre enfin enlever ce
tableau
le vote une partie donc on va aller sur
carte SCÈNE d'ailleurs je vais vous
mettre une webcam je vais mettre la
caméra où on les voit mieux je pense
sympa je pense
faut taper partout pour savoir voilà les
conseils
donc je vais je vais je vais écrire un
truc dans le chat on n'a pas le petit
échiquier pour l'instant on a juste
les
est-ce que du coup est-ce que vous avez
entendu
là je clique je clique et j'écris est-ce
que ça résume le problème ou pas
dites-moi
on entend rien on a entendu
donc tu vas faire les on va remercier
aussi fiancetto sans lui on n'aurait pas
eu tout ça donc oui il faut mettre la
partie excusez-moi les gars voilà un peu
perdu
c'est une Espagnole je pense grand
classique au niveau
donc avec 45 avec les Noirs ici donc
voilà partie elle est vraiment en toute
petite mais on voit des joueurs en grand
en 4e qui est pas chez le coiffeur
non toujours pas toujours pas bon une
relative égalitaire dans cette position
même peut-être une un petit pressing de
Carlson qui a les pièces plus active
et qui tape un peu la position de
carwana et je pense que Carlsen il va
avoir juste un objectif c'est pas
refaire ce qu'il a fait contre nepo
alors n'est pas on sait qu'il peut jouer
très vite mais quand ça n'est quand même
tombé il a mal géré sa pendule alors
qu'il est tout à fait capable de jouer
de manière brillante et en même temps de
pas se mettre dans les cordes au niveau
du temps parce que c'est ras mis à part
cette partie il reste quand même solide
le gars Carlson quoi que aujourd'hui
peut-être un petit peu moins en forme
quand même si on repense cette partie
qu'on de Richard apporte sauf c'est ça
complètement il a il a eu pas mal de
réussite dans certaines parties
donc ok voilà l'imposition calme qui est
solide en carvana bon écoutez je pense
que je pense pas qu'il va faire en ligne
il va juste jouer et puis
il peut gagner de gagner sinon non tu
vois
il va faire un pressing de la dire qu'il
va gagner ça va être réduire parce que
vous voyez les chéquiers est assez
appauvri voilà cavalier qui servait à
rien on le replace
un des meilleurs joueurs du monde 45 le
sait et puis c'est pas forcément la
partie qu'il a envie de pousser à fond
quoi il faut gagner le pion B si on veut
faire quelque chose et ensuite on jouera
avec notre pion c'est mais de la gagner
le pion B c'est difficile mais c'est ce
que carlosane essaie de faire quand un
max se fou B4 il dévisse le fousset 3
pour pouvoir travailler sur le pion B
c'est unique objectif de la position
noire dirait qu'il y a encore pénible ça
fait trois nuls que j'ai en tête ou
guéri a fait nul sans jouer avec les
mains
c'est vraiment hyper bizarre de faire ça
avec les Blancs
faire un point et demi mais en
combattant quoi il aurait pas fait guéri
il est dans le classement il est pas mal
tu vois mais voilà
que ce soit guéri on n'a pas envie de
voir ça quoi
mais il avait les noirs elle me dit bon
que tu allais noir pour moi c'était
différent trouve dans le sens il a il a
pris un noir il a essayé de jouer et
puis c'est la position ça égalisée avec
le noir tu peux pas faire grand-chose
d'accord
c'était compliqué tu vas pas prendre
tous les risques toi avec les Noirs en
plus au début mais il s'est fait un peu
avoir par l'ouverture de Magnus et puis
voilà quoi
pour pour Carsen
on a une tour très active contre une
tour passive est-ce que ça va suffire à
poser de gros problèmes c'est pas
possible
le cavalier va trouver un poste en C5 il
y a un peu le principe de deux
faiblesses maintenant le pion c'est
trois le Pione 4
qui est sur la colonne B et 3
ça sera un bon tour de force mais cawana
ne doit pas être très satisfait c'est
une position à deux résultats pour
Magnus qui empêche pour des 7 le temps
parle de lui-même en plus souffle grosse
difficulté
sur une colonne fermée
quand même les blancs un petit peu d'eau
au mur là il faut prendre tout à fait
j'avais pas vu tourner deux très
intéressantes autour des deux
c'est peut-être pour ça que tours ces
deux étaient plus précis d'abord on
vient de comprendre j'ai encore trois
quatre ici pour presser
de tour à 3 fait du pressing à regarder
on travaille la position
quand même qui est pris là
il y a échec qui peut arriver
avec des points
directs
à deux ça faisait plaisir
[Musique]
et le roi qui devient un petit peu en
réseau de maths qui peut arriver aussi
pour contrer c'est compliqué quand même
des ressources pour embrouiller Magnus
qui a dominé avec les noirs très belles
parties de Magnus est-ce que ce sera
suffisant ce qu'on peut faire KLG 5ae60
vous voyez parce qu'en fait du coup on
va réussir à virer la tour regardez
après échec trois bouge cavalier là en
défendant n'empêche bon il nous a fait
mentir mais on empêché un peu tous ces
histoires là et sur un coup de tour là
vous êtes toujours à 6 et après on
venait chasser la tour
donc là du coup il a mangé plein de
pions mais hyper G7 et après il va
sûrement perdre C7 donc
bonne soirée à toi bonne soirée bonne
journée à toi chouchou salut chouchou à
très bientôt et bonne fête de fin
d'année
donc plus mais le roi blanc qui peut un
petit peu s'activer et avec une
difficulté en plus
capable de
batnaquin donc de toute façon
si c'est bien lui que je vois à l'écran
je voyais pas
rouler d'accord
a gagné donc
quand m'a dit ça j'ai regardé le camp
qui était beaucoup mieux
donc là il y a une pièce de pub pour
garder mais le cavalier
maintenant encore mieux
et avant donc de la part de
carvana incroyable Carson qui Batman
pourquoi mais bon c'est en tout cas
c'est beau hein ce qui nous font à ce
niveau
un score monstrueux quoi
était vraiment perdant sauf s'il te
plaît
moi ce que j'ai vu la position d'avance
sur mon épaule contre
je pense parce que en tout cas j'ai cru
du coup que
Naka avait les blancs du coup s'il était
foutu mais en fait il avait ok les Noirs
alors ok il y avait une grosse attaque
pour pour en dreams
en fait il sait faire tourner de l'autre
côté
mais en fait Dame des deux en fait il y
a rien hein
ça ne marche pas du tout
[Musique]
B3 les noirs sont gagnants et c'était
bien ça du coup au moment où on a
regardé c'était déjà trop tard j'avoue
ce qui fait trop
c'est vrai ça pourrait être bon mais je
pense que on va devoir c'est
[Musique]
quand même le lit mondial là c'est un
sale appareil manque dans ce groupe de
points alors que la zavik est rapporte
vont faire sans doute match nul
pour la partie
je ne connais rien du coup en cela
c'est assez agressif pour les noirs
de plus et au niveau de l'attaque de
rocomposer il n'est pas dit que voilà il
a tout envoyé mais Jules qui joue le
gain à fond qui veut mater qui veut
mater le roi blanc il a fait peur à son
adversaire mais seulement à moitié
astuce quand même Jules pour récupérer
du matos
donc on mange ici et quel matériellement
et ben il y a quand même deux pièces
pardon c'est très intéressant de plus
mais on peut on peut comprendre déjà
pourquoi
il aurait pas voulu rentrer là-dedans
du coup
ça joue actif mais ça ne suffit pas on
prend tous les pions et je lui en fait
qui a pris l'avantage ici qui a quand
même deux pions tours de pions pour deux
pièces oui c'est fait donc il a il avait
il a eu ses chances
les tours sont actifs si vous voulez
c'est pour ça alors malheureusement le
cavalier s'est activé il faut aussi et
là ce qui était le cas il y a
il y a deux coups plus la perte du pion
G6
note il a il a vendu charmant sa peau
malheureusement
[Musique]
franco-français
tout à fait tandis que on va aller voir
la partie de
Sébastien et Sébastien qui a battu en
2300 alors 2300 Sébastien c'était le
plus jeune qu'on avait vu que c'est au
début là
c'est fait respecter
ok maintenant en tout cas on va avoir on
va avoir des belles choses je trouve
pour cette fin de fin de tournoi ça va
ça va être assez exceptionnel de suivre
le combat à distance entre les deux
grands favoris du tournoi
et car on Nakamura et le Champion du
monde en titre en rapide en partie lente
et peut-être en blitz qui venait à bout
de ce tournoi mine de rien il serait
actuellement le triple champion du monde
dans toutes les catégories aux échecs
qui est je sais même pas si ça arrivait
surtout en fait
ça peut être vraiment vraiment
exceptionnel est-ce qu'on va voir
un petit peu de jazz traddle si
exactement si on a des résultats
et je vois que non il y a encore des
parties qui sont pas rentrés quand des
résultats donc là pour le classement ça
fait 45 13 Nakamura 13 tout à fait
[Musique]
12,5
joueur et c'est 12 ans
il est pas très ambitieux on l'a vu hein
12 qui est quand même là mais on voit
que dirait qu'il y avait quand même
trois annule d'affilée quasiment avec
les Blancs
donc il essaie de grignoter des points
petit à petit pour bien figurer
on voyait pas trop les flammes de pas de
métal on comprend pourquoi j'avais dit
qu'il avait un appareil manque favorable
mais madame minov
confirmeck à 2300 bah en fait il est
super fort en blitz et il bat tout le
monde en tout cas c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout un joueur agréable à
affronter puisque
se passe qu'une perf à 2800 avant la
ronde 276
[Musique]
par rapport au hello qu'il faut
peut-être un petit litige sur un
échiquier c'est quelle partie
c'est
habitué des litiges excuse-moi un joueur
que je n'aime pas
que se passe-t-il
en tout cas il a une position un peu
difficile
mais est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on a la
cam voilà tout est bon
ça sent la norme il y a pas de norme
qui avait une position compliquée avec
le rat noir qui peut faufiler en B4
essayer d'aller attaquer les pions je
sais depuis passer GH mais deux pièces
quand même pour la tour donc on voit que
les deux joueurs ont 0 non j'arrive pas
bien le temps
si c'est 0 0 c'est pour Adli
en tout cas je suis sûr d'avoir vu tout
je vous propose d'ailleurs
bon normalement c'est l'arbitre
d'intervenir là je sais pas c'est du
jamais vu quand il y a un litige on met
pas un micro joueur
tu as l'impression que moi je pense que
Adeline va gagner
et tu as l'impression de dire parce que
il a l'impression que il lui dit un truc
du genre ouais non mais tu sais quand
même que
c'est l'arbitre qui vient
de
ce qu'ils font qui a 12 ans 12 ans
Nicolas et darin 2342
bon c'est une pépite
d'épi de russe
j'aimerais juste que un arbitrage et
prenne un petit peu les choses en main
ouais bon
il est tout jeune on l'a pendule elle a
l'affiche qu'elle a fiche donc il a dû
dire c'est tombé tiens il y a un arbitre
qui arrive avec voilà ce qui s'est passé
pas ce qui se passe malheureusement on
n'a pas le temps ils sont pas d'accord
en tout cas il y en a dit qui dit oui
l'autre qui dit non moi ça c'est sûr
mais le jeune a l'air a l'air pas
content
je comprends pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y aurait eu
[Musique]
ce que je vois c'est une potentielle
proposition nulle accepter par imaginons
par je vois pas d'autres trucs paradis
et à lit-on breton imaginons et du coup
il dit mais il m'a proposé nul j'ai
accepté voilà c'est très bizarre de
toute façon me proposer
son la partie je n'aime pas cette petite
[Musique]
partie alors que tu as pas de temps dans
l'équipe tu vois quand tu veux dire je
trouve que c'est pas très correct
il y avait un débat il y a quelques
j'avais vu quelques mois sur Facebook
sur le mur de Romain Édouard un suivi un
petit peu similaire en fait que les
joueurs
tu vois là mais il en profite là pour
réfléchir à la partie et pour voir ce
qui se passe alors que finalement il y a
il y a un problème et
c'est pas pour dire mais alors je sais
pas il y a sûrement un truc et il y a un
des joueurs qui détient la vérité enfin
les deux détiennent la vérité mais il y
en a un qui est de mauvaise foi
il est il est coutumé du fait un
complètement
et d'ailleurs il y avait il y avait eu
un truc moi j'avais même vu j'ai même
appuyé d'ailleurs tout le monde connaît
sur le chat je pense
je viens de qui avait joué contre contre
adélite il avait
vu la jaquette effectivement il a véculé
parce qu'il se lever pour la première
café et dans l'ouverture tu vois enfin
et non mais en fait écoute c'est mais il
a plein de trucs comme ça moi il m'avait
insulté sur sur Internet
c'est un jour qui aime les conflits tu
vois et
du coup bon moi je vois ça tu vois quand
même 12 ans normalement
c'est pas forcément ponctuel il aurait
deux secondes pour jouer B3
on va voir ce qui se passe mais
j'aimerais bien avoir un petit
compte-rendu savoir ce qui s'est passé
dans ce pourquoi on leur met du temps
peut-être que ce qui est possible
si on met du temps à avoir peut-être
parce qu'il a joué un coup et qu'il a
fait tomber une pièce et que du coup ça
tu vois
un gâteau parce que sinon on verrait
mais ça serait bien de demander son avis
à Hans je pense ils vont peut-être
demander les organisateurs le faire
venir pour voir si ce qu'il en pense
parce qu'en fait les caméras vous savez
qu'il y avait quand même sur sur les
quatre là on étable 90 quoi
il y a pas de tape par échec qui est pas
il y a pas un échiquier une caméra
pareille une caméra
mais sinon voilà et tu vois et ce que
j'aime pas c'est que pendant toute
problème là on voit hyper concentré et
qui profite un peu de la situation pour
essayer de piquer un pont à son
adversaire quoi en plus sur l'adversaire
oui peut-être va être chamboulé par
toute l'histoire et larguer quoi tu vois
et voilà bon après je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé à l'origine donc je peux pas
non plus être
ennemi donc c'est très bien cet ennemi
mais je tape 53
je trouve que
[Musique]
que cela manque d'élégance
malheureusement c'est un petit jeune je
veux pas donner la raison
c'était très maladroit c'est du jamais
vu non plus quoi
et là du coup tu vois
bah ça fait des minutes qui réfléchis
merci tu vois
moi
non mais franchement je suis dégoûté
bon ça va faire nul
ouais
encore une fois l'attitude t'appelle en
arbitre est-ce que
est-ce que tu as le droit d'avoir la
main comme ça au sujet
non normalement pour moi non tu vois
il y a plein de choses et après voilà
encore une fois je veux pas je veux pas
faire des vagues ni tout ça mais je sais
que c'est un genre qui est extrêmement
incorrect
ça doit être reconnu dans le circuit moi
je l'avais vu jouer à l'époque je le
connaissais pas du tout c'est pas que je
sais pas comment il était enfin je
connaissais pas toutes ces histoires là
et je l'avais vu faire une histoire
contre un joueur comme André Kim un truc
comme ça où il avait joué l'autre comate
avec trois pièces de moins et avec une
attitude complètement
bon à ce niveau là à un moment donné tu
vois
donc bon
le petit il avait gagné quoi enfin tu
vois la position tu es complètement
gagnante le petit il est hyper
déstabilisé par par la situation par
tout ce qui va se passer tu vois et
c'est très bien je dois dire que pour
cette petite embrouille ça passe au
choix du monde si vraiment il a un petit
peu arnaque et le gamin d'une manière
louche bah voilà gamin a quand même plus
de potentiel sur le long terme donc pour
un poste débile il sera décrédibilisé
complètement encore plus qui nous avait
peut-être déjà
et après on peut pas empêcher même
certaines fois
un joueur est un peu louche mais on peut
quand même avoir un litige et de bonne
foi c'est à dire que là on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé
à libre pour aussi dire je sais pas il a
fait tomber une pièce je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé machin là
c'est le jeune qui est malhonnête qui
fait ça c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas
trop dire mais après voilà par rapport à
ce que je sais du résultat c'est que
c'était généralement une histoire par
tournoi donc à un moment donné il y a un
faisceau de présomption
donc voilà les enfants mais tu vois le
gamin il a quand même l'air d'être un
d'être pas content
mais bon ok après le pas juger quelque
chose sans savoir
sans savoir est-ce que les petits jeunes
style la garde des boutons vont aller
vont aller embêter à de lit après
en tout cas il y a des interviews
j'espère que du coup on va voir ce que
tu dis stuff ok il y a eu litige etc
mais mettre la main comme tu l'as dit
rien que ça c'est anti sportif ah oui
donc oui
quand on joue une partie d'échec surtout
en blitz
il faut que tu laisses ton adversaire
appuyer sur la pendule tu vois enfin dès
que tu joue ton coup dès que lui il a
appuyé sur la pendule tu peux je
commence à être en couple et lui il a
déjà la main prête à prendre la pièce
avant même que ça et appuyer tu vois et
le fait d'avoir la main au sujet pendant
que je réfléchisse excuse-moi mais ça me
gêne tu vois en vrai c'est
en tout cas il a l'air plus dégoûté
alors
content en fait tu vois et en plus tu
vois la difficulté aussi le fait de
réfléchir
pendant le problème tu vois il y a un
problème gamin a l'air dégoûté Adly un
peu plus donc bon ok en plus pendant que
pendant le problème et ben il a il avait
il avait les mains sur sur la tête en
train de réfléchir après les rues le
clan russe pourrait donc au clan feed du
coup pour mettre une réserve
moi c'est ce que je ferais si vraiment
je me sentais dans mon bon droit je
serais un peu écœuré mais par contre
j'irai je mets une réserve vous en
faites ce que vous voulez mais
on n'arrive pas trop à expliquer max
parce que en fait si tu vois il y a pas
de caméra sur l'embrouille donc on a vu
à l'écran qui avait une embrouille tout
fermier a mis la cam et là on a essayé
d'interpréter ce qui pouvait se passer
la position initiale c'était avant le
coup 60 B3
une position où le petit jeune homme
avait avait un avantage certain et les
pendules affichés 0 seconde et 6
secondes 6 secondes pour pour le gamin
donc Nicolas qui est joué contre un
grand maître égyptien et du coup on
n'arrivait pas à comprendre en tout cas
ce qui s'est passé c'est que l'arbitre a
décidé de mettre deux secondes au Grand
Maître Adly pour qu'il puisse continuer
la partie ensuite la partie a continué
ils ont fait match nul le gamin perdu
son avantage voilà Nicolas il avait une
le petit jeune homme
donc bon il est maître feed c'est une
sorte de pépite je pense russe qui sur
long terme sera grand maître s'il
continue les échecs il y a pas de raison
vu le hello qu'il a à son jeune âge en
tout cas un peu moche parce que une
embrouille venue de nulle part mais on
n'a pas pu avoir les explications
vous verrez sûrement sur les réseaux
sociaux généralement ils aiment bien
mettre
des problèmes et conflits ça peut même
arbitrage il y a des fois il y a des
soucis donc en tout cas on verra ça je
pense sûrement aujourd'hui plus tard
dans la journée
même des fois sur facebook moi je vois
souvent vous allez sur sur la feed et la
fille en fait souvent alimentent
le fil de qualité avec plein de vidéos
de joueurs de l'interview etc et
peut-être qu'il parleront si ça donc je
vous invite aussi à toujours des
embrouilles comme ça qui existent qui
est un peu moche là c'est que c'est un
tout petit bonhomme surtout si le petit
bonhomme il est de bonne foi le petit
Nicolas
donc bon si en plus bon voilà il y a
mon C4 lit au dire de stouf et un joueur
un peu limite bon voilà après on va pas
épiloguer mais
c'est vrai que là de toute façon il
existe des règles donc les arbitres ont
appliqué les règles si le jeune joueur
avait verrine il n'est pas d'accord avec
les règles il peut poser une réserve
technique comme je le disais auprès des
organisateurs soutenu par ces
entraîneurs par le staff qui l'a
accompagné était pas venu tout seul ça
existe aussi quand on n'est pas content
d'une décision dans n'importe quel sport
qu'on estime avoir été lésé par
l'arbitrage on peut mettre une réserve
et là
un groupe
d'arbitre joueur de haut niveau peut se
rencontrer pour voir si l'arbitre a bien
respecté les règles voilà bon le truc
c'est que des jugé une partie comme ça
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué après
c'est une partie de blé pas grand chose
mais voilà on peut avoir des plein de
litiges et surtout en blitz d'ailleurs
j'arrive parce que du coup les deux
joueurs des fois sont de bonne foi ça
peut arriver entre deux joueurs qui sont
tout à fait correct parce que dans le
feu du zynote une pièce tombe machin
c'est litigieux
voilà donc du coup on a vu les gens ont
repris la partie ils ont repris la
partie
[Musique]
de Julien Song qui parle du coup de
de ce problème qu'il a eu contre ce
qu'on va mettre Julien n'est pas connu
pour avoir des embrouilles dans le
milieu des échecs donc j'avais plein
d'autres choses
[Musique]
donc bon c'est un très bon joueur
Adeline
[Musique]
de rien deux joueurs français dans le
tournoi je crois qu'il a battu même
Maxime je sais plus j'ai un doute en
tout cas je sais que c'est Mazet a fait
les frais d'adelies et je me rappelle
plus je vais regarder
pendant que je regarde mais après on
s'est trompé je crois que
si je dis pas de bêtises on a une on a
un une belle affiche table 1 on a 45
contre le MI mamadinov
et je pense qu'on va regarder ça
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Kevin oui et
à bien jouer Maxime mais n'a fait que
nul donc bon on voit que c'est un joueur
a fait exceptionnel mais
malheureusement ça c'est un petit peu
moche quoi est-ce qu'on a vu c'est pas
pour ça qu'on est venu ouais affiche
assez incroyable mais je pense que
Magnus il va bien s'appliquer et il doit
se dire que c'est plutôt un
appareillement favorable ça va être dur
pour le petit jeune homme de de résister
à la pressions entre le top player mais
l'idée c'est rigolo aussi qui arrive
mais tu vois tu vois vraiment le joueur
qui fait un très très bon tournoi mineur
tu vois c'est vraiment arrivé à la
rendre 18 et jetable 1 contre 45 c'est
un rêve qui se réalise sûrement pour ce
pour ce jeune ami il joue karaté du coup
table 1
contre sarrana pardon avec les noirs
[Musique]
donc d'ailleurs on voit le match Cyril
guéri
Sarine guéri pardon alors qu'ils sont
joués au speech il y a il y a quelques
semaines
sur un jour aujourd'hui donc plein de de
d'appariement assez palpitant
avec 10 points
donc je pense qu'ils vont essayer de de
gagner les les parties qui restent mais
c'est dur c'est dur il joue des gros
joueurs
[Musique]
matelakoff pour Gilles ça va pas être
une promenade de santé
c'est un joueur à 2700 à peu près
et San albab pour pour MBL donc les
blancs et juste au dessus avec 10 et
demi on a le genre belge pas de matériel
qui va jouer contre contre Seas avec les
Blancs bref
et voilà je crois qu'on a fait un petit
peu le tour on va un petit peu où on est
Sébastien qui a 8 points qui va jouer
gilmaz donc il masse encore un
spécialiste public ce qui a quasiment
2600 Hello
fuite la zone de jeu devrait être
interdite aux caméras alors je suis
d'accord et pas d'accord ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure
interviewer le joueur en pleine partie
c'est la première fois que je vois ça
donc pour moi c'est une petite blague
c'est ça peut pas être possible par
contre que les caméraman soit là c'est
pas gênant si tu parles pas aux joueurs
bah ça fait partie de l'organisation
c'est prévu avant il y a un règlement
tout est normalement calibré cadré moi
ça me dérange pas ça médiatise les
échecs même un litige qu'il soit filmé
ça ne me dérange pas qu'on est des
micros pour entendre ce qui se passe
avec les joueurs ça me dérange pas que
les joueurs soient interviewés ça me
dérange voilà pour te dire par rapport à
ce sujet là qui finalement sera clôturé
via les réseaux sociaux on en saura plus
comme la distoff mais c'est juste
l'interview qui était dérangeant de
gênante voilà oui l'interview c'est
c'est pas le moment quoi tu vois parce
que la partie au final la partie a
repris donc excuse-moi en fait on est en
pleine partie quoi
[Musique]
c'est comme si on interviewait lors
d'une pause ou quelqu'un est blessé
qu'un cameraman rentre sur sur la
pelouse et interview là ça s'est jamais
vu et aux échecs ça n'existe pas
normalement alors attention on est
presque à la reprise puisque là je vois
Carlson et Mama dimaff qui sont dans les
starting blocks ils sont assis
ils se font face je vais vous mettre la
vue donc je vous mets la vue normal je
pense pour que vous puissiez voir un peu
tout ce qui se passe qui doit être doit
être hyper heureux de pouvoir jouer
Carlson
table 1
franchement et c'est parti
au final parce que je pense ouais il a
envie de montrer aux petits jeunes
comment ça se passe en haut est-ce que
le petit jeune va réussir à à gérer la
pression
du monde enfin un titre de 38 ans
donc du coup
c'est assez incroyable alors en fait si
tu veux Magnus il est il a une table 1
qui est assignée
donc en fait peu importe ses résultats
etc
champion du monde et du coup ils veulent
le laisser ici
sera peut-être pas ce privilège parce
que du monde donc
peut-être que ils vont encore lui mais
bon j'imagine que le champion du monde
un nouveau changement du monde peut-être
exigera aussi à votre table
donc je pense je sais pas si ma exigé
d'ailleurs Magnus je sais pas
qui veulent le mettre mais du coup
imaginons que nepo bading pour le
championnat du monde je pense que oui
[Musique]
le numéro 1 le tableau 1 tout le tournoi
parce que parce que comment dirais-je la
gagné l'an passé cette catégorie là
on comprend ça a du sens
et le jeune mange des cadres très vite
non mais Magnus c'est incroyable parce
que Magnus c'est relativement rigolo
quand même d'avoir une minute de moins
que le petit jeune
mais il est pas content ma venue il a
l'impression de pas être content
il a fait des un peu une moule
l'ouverture n'est pas vraiment brillante
puisqu'il a une minute de moins il a
assez aidé la paire de fou c'est en réel
compensation c'est plutôt une ouverture
assez modeste je sais pas trop ce qu'il
a voulu Magnus
mais il s'est un peu trompé dans
l'ouverture alors attention rien de
grave maintenant ça va la théorie est
finie Maddie Manoff il est il est
content mais il va falloir jouer une
partie d'échec et la jouer tout un tempo
évidemment
donc t'amuser ça va être différent la
partie commence et Magnus va bien mettre
ses pièces et il attend le petit jeune
commence à bafouiller un petit peu son
placement de pièces pour lui faire mal
d'avoir donné la paire de fou le fou G4
un petit peu de mal quand même et il
pourrait peut-être redonner la paire de
fou d'ailleurs à ce moment-là où je vais
pousser 8 c'est selon on a deux façons
de voir les choses soit faut prendre des
cartes soit fou c'est vite foudez 7
n'est pas vraiment le coup je jouerai
ici avec les Noirs ça bloque un peu les
pièces autant le remettre en C8 je pense
voilà faut prendre des cartes c'était un
des motifs de la position et une partie
pour l'instant qui est assez égalisante
en tout cas je trouve que les noirs sont
même peut-être tout petit peu mieux
puisque ça va isoler le pion voilà bien
bloqué
va s'empresser à essayer de le dessin
pour recharger les pièces
peut-être peut-être
en tout cas je trouve c'est pas facile à
jouer je suis un peu gêné moi-même pour
jouer la position
madame B4 par contre là pour le coup
stouf ton dessin ne fonctionne je
pensais qu'il allait bloquer cette
opportunité là
je vous pour autre chose il a attiré la
dame dans son camp il va peut-être jouer
le tour un HK dans machisme des petits
guilis sur le roi
G4 G4 pour gagner la case 4 aussi pour
le projet enlever le fou et faire le
Cadum G5
[Musique]
comment ça va percevoir des idées qui
sont intéressantes tu peux venir avec
moi
en voyant Sadam il a oublié que son roi
était quand même un petit peu faible et
puis bon Madina il a une stratégie de
jeu bien établie c'est de mettre la
pression sur le carrousel autant je
trouve que c'est assez intelligent de sa
part maintenant c'est toujours un peu
risqué donc là j'ai l'impression on a
pas les coûts qui suivent
je vais pouvoir passer en grande
campagne peut-être histoire de la grande
cave non
il a justifié si vous voulez le pion
isolé carcène en ayant un fort jeu de
pièces qu'il n'avait pas tout à l'heure
et sur un compte du cavalier 3 cavalier
5 ou même du cavalier 4 pour venir
encore sur sa carte
noir peut-être un fou prend des 5 tours
8 vous prend des 5 puis on prend des 5
tout recettes on a des motifs de donner
le fou à certains moments pour le
spectacle et une rentrée en 7e au 8e
rangée attention
la pression temporelle c'est pas si
facile pour un Magnus de passer
au même temps
il joue très vite est-ce que
vas-y Magnus ouais ben en tout cas je
suis impressionné par la partie de
Madame minov on a complètement parce
qu'il montre une belle maturité c'est à
dire quand il a pas particulièrement
peur il joue aux échecs et on verra bien
mettre en place une trop grosse
réflexion je trouve je vais appuyer le
temps pour être sûr
je crains qu'il a
qui
va créer la surprise parce que là il
commence à devenir mieux à nouveau tout
à l'heure ma news avec toutes les pièces
actives ça n'est plus le cas et madame
je suis sûr qu'il ne s'y trompe pas il
était sous pression tout à l'heure ce
n'est plus le cas les pièces de Magnus
sont rangées
que lui il a remis le fou correct et
tout ça
n'a qu'à pas bien peut-être mais Magnus
non plus 17 secondes je pense que le
temps est bon c'est tout
de proposition de nulle avec une
simplification générale de Magnus je
pense que Magnus à l'expérience vu le
temps d'écart il va peut-être simplifier
la position pour essayer de provoquer
les échanges et peut-être proposer nul à
un moment
je vais vous mettre la caméra en plus
grand parce qu'on a un petit problème
quand même de
vous mettre la vue prochainement
madame minoff n'a pas pris de risque que
non plus ce qu'on peut comprendre il a
pas essayé de faire rouage de tour des
deux j'ai vu qu'il avait fait roi de
tour des 7 on peut le comprendre c'est
le parachute d'ailleurs pour pour Magnus
parce que Madame minov pouvait jouer
pour le gain alors que maintenant il va
jouer juste pour défendre légèrement la
position
B2 c'est vrai tu as raison après il est
vrai aussi que les pions F7 et J6
[Musique]
que le roi est arrivé en C3 on peut
faire B4
blanche et lui aussi
en pratique
c'est dur à perdre je crois quand même
[Musique]
on est vraiment désolé on a les
problèmes de connexion avec vous voyez
malheureusement
on voit que ça bug un peu
tu veux passer par là
ce serait un bon essai madame
parce que mais c'est encore possible
envoyer le pion F7 est très faible
Magnus peut essayer de faire
heureusement il tourne il va jouer à 4
F5
peut-être en plus il a moins de temps
maintenant donc ils peuvent vraiment se
faire avoir il a mis tous ses pions sur
blanc
incroyable j'ai beaucoup des trois et si
roi bouge je peux monter la finale
mais au moment de voir qu'il allait
faire un résultat contre
Magnus il commence à craquer à jouer un
peu passif à mettre cette pion sur blanc
pour bloquer comme quoi vous voyez déjà
un truc important ne mettez pas vos
pions sur case sur la carte de jouer ou
quoi
et là c'est perdu je croise tout
peut-être
il est beaucoup trop en retard
c'est sûr maintenant
il est très déçu je pense
sur la diagonale blanche
[Musique]
possible vous avez la caméra quand même
sur les joueurs
voilà c'est terminé les pions qui avance
ouais
[Musique]
quel dommage qu'elle déception il est je
pense très déçu parce qu'il vient ouais
voilà regardez vous voyez c'est dur à
accepter
de accepter parce que
il tenait le champion du monde il tenait
pour nul c'est sûr mais même peut-être
mieux regardez comme c'est dur pour un
pour un jeune homme comme ça bien sûr
c'est une belle partie mais
vous avez vu quand dans quel état il a
quitté le
stade complètement
on a qu'à foutu contre Sarana
un point d'avance sur Naka attention
motif de pâte excusez moi la caméra qui
n'est pas la bonne nouvelle
qui perd un très mauvais moment il a plu
son destin entre les mains
cette première journée enfin sa dernière
journée de Blitz et qui maintenant est à
un point derrière
donc peut-être que c'est nul de salon
vont lui coûter cher exactement c'est
pas pour nous déplaire une amie
il a fait trop de nul je suis d'accord
franchement c'est pas
il a pour l'instant il y en a qui ont
des études irréprochables et d'autres
qui font des petits nuls tout ça
bon ben on voit qu'au final pour
l'instant ça n'a pas amené une aka sur
performer ces moments de pause
faut rester chaud au moins on peut rien
regretter si on a toujours
au bout aussi envoyer une belle nulle de
combat nul c'est pas grave aux échecs
c'est un excellent résultat si vous êtes
donné les moyens d'aller au bout
pas de métal là je vois de la flamme
il y a de la flamme dans le chat
[Musique]
mais pas tout le temps pour nous ouais
c'est trop tard c'est très contre
une fois que tu es là je passe là dans
le roi par n'importe où sans la dame
pour l'aider c'est joli le mat
normalement dame faux contre dames
évidemment vous savez c'est nul c'est
quasiment morte on met les pièces sur la
couleur inverti
comment était la position au départ de
cette finale s'il te plaît stuff pour
voir juste si
normalement cette position alors voilà
faut jamais dire un perdant parce que
il a juste à continuer les échecs
ici et le roi blanc qui a aidé au maths
là par exemple ici
on a une partie avec deux jeunes qui se
joue là je sais pas comment ils
appellent je sais pas qui c'est du coup
je ne peux plus du mal à l'avoir
une partie cellule
je veux pas la partie
j'ai
peut-être je vais 4 pour monter un petit
peu
tu vois les joueurs qui sont qui sont
vraiment et qui joue tranquille ils
savent que même si dans peu de temps la
pendule et sont tranquilles tu vois
F5 aurait chaque endiago voilà
tu es tellement cool qu'il aurait fini
par oublier le temps et il va falloir
c'est le métier qui rentre c'est pas
grave on s'arrête
[Musique]
2300 pas de coffre 2410
on peut bien sûr dans ces moments-là
puis les joueurs commencent à fatiguer
on rappelle que ça fait 5 jours de
compétition pour les joueurs
ça reste des parties à haute intensité
des rebondissements
dur pour le cœur dur pour la tête tout
est difficile alors que du coup je vais
regarder les les résultats sur mon petit
test
voir si toutes les notations vont
rentrer et c'est le cas tous les
résultats sont rentrés la ronde 19 n'est
pas encore sorti mais elle va arriver on
a 45 à 14 points
et qui est ça en tête maintenant avec
combien d'avance je crois il a un point
d'avance sur sur martyrrosant et sur
Naka
c'est un point net
à 12h30
sur les autres donc celle qui commence à
apprendre une une belle option avec
trois rondes par an à suivre dans le
championnat
il nous reste plus que trois rondes pour
décerner le titre de champion du monde
sur trois rondes à 2 sur 3
un 2 sur 3 assuré quasiment peut-être à
Carlsen la première place
parce que
je trouve que Max Magnus est un peu
moins dominant que d'habitude je trouve
qu'il a eu beaucoup de réussite non
provoquées si tu veux je touche pas ce
que tu en penses mais par rapport à
d'habitude où il est écrasant
exceptionnel je le trouve un peu moins
fort mais par contre il a de la réussite
alors d'habitude c'est plutôt Naka qui
l'a qui la provoque la Magnus sans rien
faire la partie qui vient de faire il y
a celle de kondrie char rapporte où il a
pas provoqué il est complètement dominé
il se bat évidemment parce que il doit
rester dans le match honnêtement pas mal
de réussite pour le gamin nus
aujourd'hui oui clairement après bon il
y a d'autres compétition il y a beaucoup
de fatigue un peu pour tout le monde et
puis aussi le fait tu sais c'est rien
mais le fait de jouer contre Magnus et
ben il y a un problème une pression
supplémentaire là tu vois le joueur qui
a qui avait les Noirs contre Magnus et
ben il aurait peut-être joué
différemment s'il a dit en face
pédagogique la finale de Magnus contre
maradinaire parce qu'en fait tu vois
attends je vais mettre la position si
vous voulez rapidement en plus analyser
un petit un tout petit peu je vais vous
remettre la caméra
en plus
avant que les tours soient échangés
parce qu'il avait un choix pratique très
intéressant pour jouer pour le gain
madame minov regardez cette position
il a joué échec et ici la plus autoroute
des deux pour essayer d'aller me bouffer
les pions mais non en fait il respecte
beaucoup au Mali tête on fait nul et
bien sûr que c'est la tour par ben c'est
égal quoi du coup Carcel est célibataire
je vais la jouer on jugeait 5 et on va
fixer des pions sur cache blanche hyper
intéressant c'est que vous savez dans
les finales de Bordeaux c'est souvent
nul facilement mais avec plus de même
couleur et ben il faut éviter de mettre
ses pions sur
vos cases François regarde du coup parce
que vous voyez que là le problème qui va
se passer
et après le roi soit actifs vous voyez
et ben au final le problème des Noirs
ici lorsqu'on moins bien parce que les
pions sont en face blanche donc après
qui est
sûrement assez facilement nul avec un
comme vous aussi et puis on touche plus
à rien tu vois mais dès que tu bouges un
pion en fait de l'aile de l'aile dingue
ici et ben tu auras un problème ouais il
a joué à 4 un petit peu les lions blancs
ce qui est peut-être pénible quand même
vous voyez que c'était nul cette
position je t'avais dit b5.6 c'est
d'ailleurs l'ordinateur il pense que
c'est nul en pratique on pense que c'est
nul aussi mais au final ce qui fait
c'est qu'il met des forces blanches et
plus tard et ben ça peut poser des
problèmes en terme de technique avec
tous les pions ce qui sont des
faiblesses et si tu joues B5 pour que je
B4 il peut te dire que c'est bien mais
là c'est pareil parce que je regarde
moi-même et au final ton pion est super
grand c'est là toutes les pièces
deux faiblesses et B5 je vais attaquer
là je vais provoqué pour 8 je vais
bouger un petit pion et du coup le fou
pourra pas bouger à cause du la défense
depuis
je pourrais venir là attaquer
au fur et à mesure ça va gagner des
positions et
du coup
il a pas réussi à tenir le choc mais
hack A4 B5 fois si c'est très difficile
de trouver un spot pour
pour
juste en pratique ne mettez pas
moi que j'aurais fait je pense j'aurais
peut-être perdu mais j'aurais le fou
aussi et j'aurais attendu
je pense parce que je préfère éviter de
mettre les pions sur la couleur du four
adverse par de l'autre bout parce que du
coup mon coup va être voué à la défense
et que en tournant en tournant tournant
tournant comme un fait Magnus et va au
final elle est un peu se tromper et puis
pendant la partie on va voir la partie
regarder A4 ouais enfin
il attend
du coup
D7 voilà le 5
qui m'embête c'est qu'il aurait pu
éviter la venue du Fou en E8 quoi
c'était déjà c'est déjà une bonne chose
après précédemment quoi si tu veux quand
il avait le front E6 il est il avait pas
besoin de laisser faire foudre B5 ici
c'est plus logique
B5 OK
c'est ça que je voulais jouer je veux
pas d'intrusion de fou je crois pas que
tu puisses m'empêcher
ouais j'ai du mal à
défense foutait
une partie tu penses pas forcément qui
recule c'est 4 c'est des coups où en
fait le fou des fois et du coup ça a
l'air plus solide et dans la pratique tu
vois
j'ai plus amené ce type de foot
est-ce qu'on était perdant parce que
ça commence à être dur en fait parce que
au final
on commence à ne plus bouger roi des
trois c'est malin Magnus ça commence
est-ce que j'ai droit de faire roi F4 là
pour partir
et je pose des problèmes pratiques
c'est pour ça que ça me disait pas trop
le fait de mettre des pions
doivent rester la défense et c'est le
problème de paix à moi mon Roi peut
monter avec les Blancs parce que tes
pions avant je m'en fous je suis libre
alors que les tiens le fou doit rester
là pour défendre elle est le roi de
rester là-bas et au final ben j'ai plus
de d'activité et
comme ça on a bien compris la finale si
le noir pour tenir devait empêcher
l'intrusion du fou pour pouvoir faire
une sorte de défense passive et le
conseil pratique que vous donne tout
c'est bien sûr d'éviter de mettre tous
les pions sur blanc parce que vous voyez
que le faux 8 est surpuissant parce
qu'il attaque les faiblesses placées sur
blanc justement le pion B5 ça rend
mécaniquement les pièces noires esclaves
et là on peut plus rien faire on se
retrouve en dessous voilà véritable et
on finit par céder du terrain comme
Carlson nous l'a montré magnifique
il a fait jouer un petit peu le
l'expérience quoi
et puis on voit une perdus mais si il
avait bougé le feu à la place j'aurais
eu fou des trois sûrement qui va
attaquer ici et sur folie
comment tu passes exactement
la foudre
ça restait encore
en pratique c'est ça l'art compliqué F4
encore fou aussi ce qui n'est pas
miracle
aussi
besoin
plus vite dans la partie
les pions c'est aussi une erreur parce
que les plantes ont pris plus vite que
normalement
de venir donc là on voit Sarah nakarsen
Douda martyrosian Naka shimanov et vous
l'afficher en première
là ça va ça va
contre un Sarana qui est obligé de
gagner s'il veut faire tomber Carlsen ça
peut être bien il peut se régaler
avec les Blancs
[Musique]
il venait à batnaque avec suivre
complètement relancé c'est chaud avec
Maxime
c'est le joueur d'Internet qui est très
très bon très dangereux
wonderful life je crois sur
ma mise à jour des scores je crois alors
maximiler il a 11 ah oui j'ai pas j'ai
pas changé ça moi je peux pas le faire
donc
c'est juste pour te dire comme ça vous
allez pouvoir
voilà on arrive
il reste trois rondes
et Seb on a un peu laissé tomber ouais
pas mal ouais il revient à 26 ça doit
lui faire plaisir à ça parce que il
était un petit peu au fond du trou là
avec à la faveur de cette victoire il va
revenir pour jouer des Mac très
intéressants il va pouvoir
accrocher à son tableau de chasse ouais
sinon il sera il sera déçu et il y a un
joli job Bava à Mazet nous dit kovitch
cool
on va regarder un petit peu donc du coup
Jul
c'est un comment mettre en 2006 c'est un
russe
pas facile toujours
avec 9 et demi
tu as le 33 là
elle est partie avec Jordan van forest
aussi qui aurait pu être un bon Paris
mais il est trop loin du coup par
rapport à par rapport à nos Paris juste
mais Carson tous les deux maintenant
il est pas mal pour l'instant
et c'est dur de toute façon et donc là
tu es quand même vachement mieux que moi
dans ces résultats
mvlan
on va pas la voir
et par rapport au 3 il faut voir nous on
a les trois même toi en plus les joueurs
sont à table les joueurs sont à table
ils sont pris en déco ça va démarrer
d'ici une minute pour ceux qui alors du
coup tu regardes on se les regarde
encore une fois
c'est vrai que
tu as mis 10 à Jules
c'est juste que Gaïa nous surveille elle
veut pas qu'on fasse de bêtises je vous
remercie dans le chat
alors vous enlevez ça je vais vous
mettre la vue
normal de suivre Carlsen pour moi c'est
le champion du monde
à partir de moment où il est vraiment en
tête c'est logique en plus il a nos
faveurs
[Musique]
je pense que c'est cool de regarder de
regarder 45 qui qui est champion du
monde en rapide en classique et qu'il a
qui joue pour pour le titre de champion
du monde
en blitz le triplet
donc avec
avec 4 c'est sympa
de la part de Savannah qui propose un
truc
faire nulle avec avec les pièces noires
il peut donc il va pas essayer
nécessairement de faire nul mais en tout
cas il va jouer simple
ce qui veut dire que s'il fait pas un
peu de nul il faut que Naka fasse
deux victoires pour rattraper
ne perds perdre ici et gagner avec les
Blancs et là il pourra voir pour la
dernière ronde comment comment faire
c'est ça
qu'il a quand même eu de la réussite
donc il va pas faire
il va pas faire
ça
mais en même temps Sarana avait fait un
début assez rigolo avec E3 fois 5 F3
avec des idées comme le début jobava de
faire G4 H4 vraisemblablement
de pousser les pions
avoir l'expansion pourquoi pas obligé
oui mais bon c'est quand même
obligé de regarder cars scène je sais
pas ça il y a plusieurs lectures
je sais pas je sais pas je pense que je
pense que Néandertal se risquait pas à
jouer à chaque dans tous les poésies je
sais pas c'est tout
à bien avancer ton centre de pions c'est
pas c'est quoi rapidement sur H5
et il avance concentre
ce que fait Magnus c'est à dire qu'il a
donné tout le centre et la réaction
c'est 5 est très difficile à jouer dans
cette position puisque les Blancs n'ont
plus le foot de casse blanche donc des 5
ne bloquent pas les pièces blanches
après on s'est un centre pendant c'est à
dire que ce sont des pions pendant 4 et
des cartes sur des colonnes
semi-ouvertes pas soutenu avec des pions
tout donc peut-être qu'on peut se les
faire taper avoir
j'aime pas la position cardiale non
parce que le petit la culture
et le centre des gens qui arrivent le 15
de 4 pour le cavaliers qui va qui va
venir aussi
je suis pas fan je suis pas vraiment
moins bien que d'habitude souffre parce
que d'habitude vraiment il maîtrise tout
on le voit pas moins bien presque dans
les parties
en fin de fatigue et peut-être comme
championnats du monde là de faire le
numéro 1 mondial
il reste trois parties il a plus un sur
le tournoi mais
je le trouve beaucoup plus possible que
d'habitude franchement d'habitude il est
extraordinaire et là on voit que
des parties il est maîtrise moins si tu
veux
n'importe quoi mais
il est en difficulté je pense dans cette
position
je vois bien gagner suite à
le service de qualité j'aime beaucoup
quand même je trouve c'est un bon choix
pratique c'est ça ou la mort
peut-être je sais pas mais c'est qui
avait l'air assez intéressant mais pour
apprendre et tout refaire
ça a l'air extrêmement extrêmement
compliqué
il joue avec sa qualité de manière hyper
intéressante il ouvre les colonnes il
rentre ses tours du classique il profite
du matériel d'avance
souvent après sur le pion des 4 et
attention
il va tenir il va essayer en tout cas il
va essayer de tenir son aura de champion
du monde
mais joue parfaitement j'ai l'impression
que
[Musique]
en
il a bien joué toi il a été très précis
mais qui a eu des 8 qui aurait eu un
coup de tour prise du pion à 7 par la
suite
incroyable du coup du coup le tournoi se
relance complètement
c'est pas la pression c'est juste qu'il
est crevé on voit que je vous en parlez
je le vois pas du tout dans les mêmes
dispositions que d'habitude d'habitude
est très dominant dans ces parties c'est
quasiment un jeu parfait stuff nous
parler des scientifions du niveau auquel
il arrivait à jouer et là il a pris une
raclée avec Sarana qui est un très très
beau joueur des chats
donc 2700 on va dire mais c'est rare de
voir Magnus souffrir il a souffert
contre un joueur qui est très bon en
blitz précédemment mais qui est 24 1938
là il se fait écraser par un 2007 c'est
pas le Magnus habituel et ce qui va
réussir à se remobiliser pour les deux
dernières rondes là je pense qu'il est
parti il est parti faire un truc mais il
va falloir
partir de la kaki qui souffre contre
shimanov bien sûr ils sont dangereux
tous ces joueurs je suis maintenant faut
le voir très souvent
et c'est un mec les gens dans ces
cadences là je vois à peu près à 2600
mais 2650 peut-être mais
bien plus fort encore en cadence rapide
très dangereux
alors le point situation vous avez le
score des Français sous le chat ma
copine et au niveau du niveau enfin du
niveau du tournoi et Ben karacène qui
avait un point d'avance surnaka vient de
perdre
contre una qui remonte à un de mes
points de 45 et si Nakamura gagne sa
partie et ben il va faire aussi
quinzaine donc c'est pas sûr c'est pas
sûr
après il a réussi à mettre un peu la
pression il y avait pion à 7 un petit
peu en prise je pense qu'il va devoir le
prendre et essayer de faire nulle
et il va rester de tenir la finale de
cavalier prend un step avec des prix
bon shimanov normalement c'est une
position à deux résultats il doit
envoyer
et mais pour gagner il faut mettre la
tour en 1 sans doute et c'est un risque
parce qu'il y a des tourbées 7 qui a des
six donc c'est dur à gagner quand même
je crois qu'il a gagné
en ce moment ça doit faire pleurer pas
de métal mais qui prend du plaisir pas
de métal dit qu'il y a du chaud
très tendu
il peut il est capable d'un hold-up à
tout moment
c'est un tout en mille fois plus fort
dans le
il est très vicieux comme quoi
exactement
et c'est ça
commence à laisser des plumes au niveau
du temps de grosses grosses plumes
quand ça s'accélère on sait que ma
caille il est pas mal à droite du tout
du tout du tout parce que c'est la
pendule
ils ont fait nul
ils ont dû faire mal
[Musique]
en gagnant il a presque tournoi gagné
manus il vient d'envoyer son tournoi
pas la poubelle bien sûr mais il a gâché
une belle opportunité mais il a quand
même toujours un petit peu d'avance
et oui trop dur pour pour darda contre
Fabiano très très fort
une nouvelle pour se donner un peu de
terre et ml abattu le tueur le retour
mais le problème c'est qu'il est parti
de trop loin ça retourne un peu trop
tard trop d'élan pour Maxime je vais
vous mettre la caméra ou de la salle
et est-ce qu'on est parti à boire il y a
ni même si vous voulez voir
qui qui a les blancs il a battu Nayer
et la caméra on voit Stéphane Aubin qui
a été champion du monde
on peut faire un petit vu qu'on parle
des femmes parce que dans le tournoi des
femmes c'est 17 rondes stouf donc c'est
bientôt fini on est à la ronde à
l'avant-dernière ronde on a la ronde ça
sur 17
et stefanova c'est la table 2 elle joue
contre tan
on va voir Seb aussi
[Musique]
je ne vois pas
Seb
il est où
papa
les gens sont fatigués
[Musique]
il a perdu
qu'on avait beaucoup vu hier
ça a gagné
il doit être un petit peu loin
maintenant
dans le classement là dans les parties
que je cherche
[Musique]
la difficulté la dureté ce tournoi
on va pouvoir retravailler waterfaut je
vais pas reparié à tout
j'aurais pu parler à toi mais je sais
pas que le monde
[Musique]
pas se faire avoir
et dans la
2 défenses à la défense en 7e rangée
qu'il a eu un moment et l'autre c'est le
fait de clouer la défense au crâne de
clouer
quand le roi est en cinquième il faut en
4e rangée surtout pas quand le roi est
en sixième rangée et le fou en 5e rangée
parce que il y a des réseaux de maths
qui se créent
donc on alterne entre les deux défenses
généralement
il est en train de très bien faire et
spenco si
rasante avait eu cette aisance les anses
bah ça aurait été bon
du coup il va continuer jusqu'à
quasiment être enfin pas continuer au
maximum et si il était foutu normalement
il aurait la malice de réclamer la règle
des 50 coups pour évaluer le nombre de
coups joués ça fait les joueurs ils ont
ils ont joué les coups suffisants il a
l'air de défendre en sifflotant
d'ailleurs ici Penko demande
il pourrait même attendre l'enfilade
mais à chaque fois il repars en défense
coquerrane donc c'est à dire qu'il
arrive à faire nulle facilement
donc là il y a pas trop de problèmes
quand il y a certains joueurs comme ça
qui sont habitués si vous voulez à
défendre
pour très longtemps ce genre de position
c'est pas la première fois la joue il la
défend un tempo il y a des joueurs qui
sont entraînés j'ai déjà joué contre un
joueur biélorus qui a fini troisième au
championnat d'Europe des jeunes et il
avait il avait défendu en si flottant et
jouer plus vite que moi et trois tours
alors que j'avais roi turfu j'étais un
peu deg que j'avais vu des grands mains
de la perdre dans le tournoi j'estimais
avoir pas si mal attaqué mais c'est nul
théorique si votre adversaire défend
bien c'est pas facile
donc là on voit que il se passe rien
depuis tout à l'heure et si Benco est en
train de s'assurer il fait beaucoup
beaucoup de coups
c'est pas mal d'ailleurs
en tout cas défense très impressionnant
de Stephen
problème
à un moment donné
c'est plus quoi et c'est plus comment
tourner you c'est assez rigolo
on peut réclamer la règle des 50 coups
et 6,75 coups sont joués l'arbitre peut
intervenir
nous confirmer ça
on a nos arbitres dans le chat
et l'adversaire d'ailleurs avait l'air
de dire OK
c'est assez marrant qui est pas
un arbitre proche quand même il y a
beaucoup de tables tu bon là il y a
beaucoup mais alors c'est assez récent
à peu près la règle je dirais stuff des
75 chevaux c'est d'ailleurs pour les 5
fois la même position ça arrive la règle
officielle c'est trois fois la même
position vous pouvez régler 6 5 fois la
même position se reproduit sur
l'échiquier l'arbitre peut intervenir et
d'ailleurs là l'arbitre a confirmé la
demande des CIP and Co
léger litige c'est à dire qui est là du
dire nul à l'arbitre comme ça pas
vraiment réclamé avec la forme et du
coup
l'arbitre a dû à dû lui dire qu'est-ce
que tu demandes ou quelque chose comme
ça j'ai l'impression que c'était
le petit petit litige donc là les
parties sont terminées les appareils
vont pouvoir être édités et on a Magnus
qui reste en tête mais il vient de
perdre quand même et
son matelas s'amuse avec un Hikaru qui
va le talonner d'un demi point c'est
dommage
c'est un peu un enfer pour pour
[Musique]
Maxime pour pour quarantaine qui en peut
plus on voit la fatigue vraiment il joue
pas très bien par rapport à son niveau
réel si on se permet de dire ça vous
savez qu'on est grand soutien de Magnus
c'est pas du tout péjoratif c'est
vraiment qu'on constate que il n'y ait
pas
pourtant il est premier mais la qualité
de jeu n'est pas bonne heureusement
qu'il a un petit peu comme le disait
stouf son aura qui lui permet d'avoir
des livraisons de ces adversaires des
petites nuls par-ci par là
heureusement aussi que Naka est pas en
super forme tout le monde est fatigué en
fait attention à Douda qui revient
d'ailleurs à 13 et demi c'est un client
Bouddha on le sait il était en finale
l'an dernier contre de contre mvl voilà
avec ce match de partage ou mvl avait
arraché le titre de champion du monde de
la catégorie Blitz donc cette catégorie
Blitz en 3 + 2
on va voir mais peut-être que la
fraîcheur pourrait venir du joueur
polonais qui était pas devant tout le
temps donc attention à Yann Christophe
Douda
toujours en tête tout seul
avec
Nakamura et qui ont très ennemis qui
sont juste derrière qui est
avec pas mal de gens aussi à 13 points
comme artemiev on va doubaf on voit des
pots on voit Jerry Kemer non gamer 12 et
demi pardon on voit beaucoup de joueurs
quand même puis on bien sûr très ennemis
aussi on a aussi Savannah
donc on a trois joueurs à un demi point
de caractère extrêmement chaud je vais
voir si on est apparemment de
l'avant-dernière bronze qu'il y a 21
euros et là on va commencer la ronde
numéro 20 en blitz
notre petit mvel il vient de faire 5 sur
5 et commencer son sprint de fin mais il
a démarré trop malheureusement il a pris
trop de retard mais il a fait il a mal
démarré cette journée après il enchaîne
les victoires alors il est tombé un peu
plus bas aussi ça l'aide mais après
maintenant les joueurs vraiment forts
donc il peut encore terminé avec deux
mais en terminant avec
dit seulement à cause du mauvais
départage qu'il aura
[Musique]
14 c'est des points que Magnus 1
maintenant dorénavant la fin donc il
fera un top 10 sûrement mais pas plus
c'est ça
donc on va voir un peu ce qui va se
passer
est-ce qu'on a du coup
les apparuments je vais checker donc WTD
il va pas il va pas revenir donc
je vais vous les montrer on a shimanov 4
scène
je voulais montrer
hop à Paris non est-ce que il va réussir
à tenir dans la tête notre bon Magnus
contre Sarana donc Sarana qui a un bon
apparemment qui qui joue qui est qui est
pas mon fort que lui et qui prend
quelque chose il peut être champion du
monde hein il est très dangereux il a un
demi point de vente Magnus il est à
Wagnac et Douda qui meurt contre
et André kill contre
[Musique]
suivant de de quarantaine c'est Sarana
Nakamura et Douda avec seulement un demi
point de moins c'est ça tout reste
encore possible
et toutes les parties sont hyper chaudes
vous voyez que en vrai kind Douda
franchement c'est 50 50
de terrasser un joueur comme Nakamura
étable de base c'est pour moi c'est
carrément 55 ans aussi et table 1 bah
évidemment Carsen et favori il a plus de
points mais qui manoeuf il est auteur
d'un super tournoi aussi et il vient de
faire du coup on a qu'à et donc bah
écoutez encore tout est possible même
une simple nul de 45 pourrait le mettre
dedans parce que vous voyez qu'une nul
pourrait faire revenir tous les joueurs
dans le tournoi bien sûr et à table 5 6
il y a encore des à 13 points qui
pourrait se glisser artémief n'est pas
et du bœuf et sinon le reste c'est trop
loin on voit quand même vel jouera
d'ailleurs Harry Krishna table 9 c'est
pour revenir dans le tournoi et Jules on
n'oublie pas table 12 avec les Noirs
contre Alexander grichu Sacha du coup ça
sera pas facile non plus mais au moins
il se fait plaisir on l'attendait à ce
niveau là Jules il a peiné au début de
tournoi et après il a fait quelque chose
de grand voilà comment s'est passé pour
lui donc voir aussi quand même que 45
doublé noir ça fait deux fois d'affilée
qu'il a les noirs
donc les plans la dernière
on peut trip
ler une dernière ronde
[Musique]
c'est des caractères donc je pense pas
que ça n'arrivera ici dans ce tournoi
donc on peut imaginer que Carlson aura
les blancs à la prochaine donc si il
gagne par qui là il est quand même pas
mal
assez peu perdre même si c'est un bide
normalement contre shimanov on va dire
que il a une marge même avec les noirs
très importante un shimanov c'est un
joueur que j'ai déjà joué au teach
Tuesday tout ça mais quand même Shimano
fait en très grande forme et à l'inverse
Magnus il a montré des signes de
faiblesse
il faudrait qu'il revienne la revigorer
après cette partie ultra rapide c'était
comme une ronde de repos qui s'est prise
là mais avec la défaite au bout
on l'a vu en difficulté maintenant sur
les deux trois dernières rondes quatre
dernières rondes
donc il faut qu'il se refasse
pour regarder
on est quasiment on est obligé de voir
ce qui se passe dans les premières
tables pour le titre de champion du
monde il reste deux parties
dans le carton qui est en tête je vous
rappelle avec un demi points de plus que
trois c'est poursuivants Parana qui
vient de bangers du coup Nakamura et
Douda et avec 13 points on a quand même
pas mal de gens aussi on a un marteau on
a reténéfe
on a guéri beaucoup de joueurs qui sont
pas loin une défaite de caractère le
matricule complètement dedans pour le
coup
par contre une nul hein serait encore
envisageable mais bien sûr ici Cartier
une nouvelle chanson du monde il veut te
montrer que c'est le plus fort et du
coup on attend quand même un quartier
un petit blague marre de shimanov
histoire de finir en beauté ou alors
peut-être au black Mark de Carlson
dernière ronde non mais Shimano qui fait
quand même un combat très solide etc
tu vois du coup bon il y a aucun
aucun risque toujours un truc comme ça
[Rires]
non mais tu connais Néandertal je pense
que c'était petite face ici et c'est
vrai qu'il avait démarré modestement
remarque qu'il avait elle avait trois
sur trois il a pris deux bulles contre
j'irai dubaf il venait de Bad nepo en
début de tournois la paix en fait il a
perdu guéri André Keane Douda gritchouk
et c'est tout
et je peux te dire qu'il a battu
Shankland visite you paravian qui est
pas qui est loin d'être nul donc nepo
qu'on a cité donc en fait on l'a pas
trop vu parce qu'on passe suivre tout le
monde mais shimanov fait un énorme
tournoi
le message de robinsight qui dit
qu'apparemment il fait super chaud dans
salle de jeux et ça affecte pas mal de
joueurs qui sont tout le temps tout le
temps une bouteille d'eau
aller voir ce que souvent
il faut être des fois en Costa et tout
et s'il fait chaud c'est dur aucun
accent le 30 décembre et il doit ils
doivent pas non plus
il doit pas non plus faire si chaud donc
ça veut dire que ils font il faut pas
trop attention à la rigueur énergétique
apparemment dans la salle de jeux
[Musique]
pas mal cette question qui revient de
manière récurrente parce que ça aurait
été un candidat au titre comme beaucoup
d'autres
qu'il se prépare sur des cadences plus
lentes c'est l'explication à la fois
plausible et aussi assez sympa
parce qu'on a envie de le voir performer
en partie lente performer dans le tronc
des candidats pour s'offrir une chance
de conquérir le titre mondial dans la
catégorie des parties lentes la
catégorie reine donc du coup je vois
qu'il y avait un débat sur le chat avec
mvl mvl ne peut plus
être en cours du monde c'est
mathématiquement
impossible imparti il a deux points de
moins que 45 qui fera pas 0 et même si
grave entre eux font tous au pire
exactement donc voilà par contre un
podium je le crois pas du tout parce que
même à 14 points
VL un départage qui est trop pourri donc
de toute façon je pense que même un
produire avec deux points sur deux ça
sera juste pas possible par contre avec
deux sur deux un beau top 10 tu as c'est
clair même top 5 peut-être même si je
crois pas trop quand même pense que
c'est un top 10 en 4 de victoire et
après pas de métal pour la Belgique on a
Torix qui ne demande un petit peu des
nouvelles des joueurs suisses je pense
qu'il est donc Suisse lui-même ça je te
risque qu'il y a quelques grands mètres
quand même Suisse après oui ça reste
assez modeste et on a Yannick Pelletier
qui a un joueur compotitait qui est
extrêmement fort est-ce que tu as
d'autres idées de joueurs suisses qui
en grand maître
qui ont peut citer dans dans les jeunes
il y en a quelques-uns j'ai cours man il
y a moins fort il est 24 60 à peu près
c'est vraiment le plus fort
il y a pas de joueurs vraiment à plus de
2006-2007 quoi en tout cas
je dis une bêtise ou quand il a joué sur
le drapeau suisse
quoi oui voilà c'est ça
exactement
donc
un moment d'ailleurs en France on avait
beaucoup de grands maîtres français
d'origine russe en fait en réalité
voilà donc oui les Suisses c'est pas
voilà culturellement inscrit
donc dans le pays enfin le jeu d'échec
n'est pas culturellement inscrit mais
comment en France ensuite c'est pareil
en Belgique c'est pareil petit à petit
le GD chaque prend sa place et on a des
joueurs forts de haut niveau
salut comment
et salut à tous ceux qui viennent
d'arriver donc il reste deux parties
dans du monde on voit que les joueurs
commencent à s'installer
du coup on va on va suivre un capitaine
parce que c'est quand même la fin du du
championnat qui est en tête vous mettre
la vue la vue normale qu'on faisait bien
voir les fessier ainsi que les joueurs
aussi
qui arrive
voilà là on va se régaler un c'est
vraiment le bon état c'est le moment
qu'on doit avoir
je vais vous mettre j'ai pas mis la
caméra
si si moi je ouais je pensais bien que
tu me connaissais après je peux pas
savoir d'où exactement parce que c'est
difficile de donc on connaît des gens
avec tout par internet ou des gens qu'on
a vu en réel dans les combats on sait
jamais mais souvent quand les gens te
reconnaissent ils mettent un petit
message sympa du coup c'est cool
et du coup maintenant gros match stuff
si Cassen venait à gagner il s'assure de
finir sur le podium voire peut-être
mieux en cas de défaillance de de Naka
et des autres mais il devra jouer ces
deux rondes à une mission
champion parce qu'il aura les blancs la
prochaine
je le vois pas faire avec la fatigue
tout est possible le quart de shimanov
c'est parti on va envoyer oui il aime
bien la française la française
du côté noir
donc on a vu sur la caméra qui a Jacques
cavalier step malheureusement on a
encore des lags
il est numéro 1 il a 14 points
et demi dont Nakamura pour donner
rapidement le classement à ceux qui
n'ont pas vu quand on l'avait mis et là
on vient de l'enlever pour se concentrer
sur les joueurs
et on est avant dernière ronde du
tournoi donc 4 14 45 et 13 et demi
Nakamura avec duda et Sarana voilà le
classement un joueur en tête suivi de
trois joueurs avec un demi point de
moins ok bon ça a l'air salaire solide
pas de souci
il a la paire de fou mais on échange
Shimano enfin meilleur centre
pour les Noirs
la prochaine bah on sait que shimanove
d'ailleurs il est il est très fort il
l'a montré
peut-être un peu plus lent que ce gratin
des des meilleurs joueurs mondiaux pour
l'instant il n'a pas montré mais il a
les blancs
mais c'est plus dans le Bullet ou ultra
Bullet qui pourrait se faire avoir dans
le monétaire mais on voit qu'en tout cas
je suis Manoff il a pas pris de risque
il est là juste pour
bloquer carcène et Magnus va essayer
d'améliorer ses pièces
moi je vois pas trop comment moi je sais
pas si Magnus pourrait pas tenter un
petit quelque chose tu sais j'ai si je
l'améliore comme il sait faire tu vois
au moins il y a pas grand risque pour
lui je pense qu'il va essayer il sait
qu'il est meilleur que le joueur quand
même en face qui est très bon shimanov
un grand maître à 2600 si vous voulez un
peu plus longue Magnus donc il peut le
presser un petit peu tout dépend de
sa volonté à Magnus de jouer cette
position mais bon c'est vrai que nous
même avec stouf bon là il joue à 5 donc
il a envie de faire quelque chose
attention quand même mais dans ces
positions avec stouf on a les a déjà
joué contre des joueurs plus faibles
allez imaginons 100 points l'autre moins
c'est pas facile de passer même avec
toute la bonne volonté du monde
c'est une carte symétrique et
c'est quand même même si les moins fort
c'est quand même un excellent joueur il
y a pas rouler dessus aussi pertinent
c'est vrai donc
il y a juste le contexte psychologique
on voit que shimanov il a pas envie de
prendre de risques ou alors pour prendre
les risques il faut vraiment que la
position soit très avantageuse qui la
sentent bien il a eu des petites
opportunités maintenant avec les Noirs
la problématique c'est qu'on a un peu
bloqué comment on améliore cette
position comment on pose des problèmes